but just pearly things YouTube channel
and welcome to the pregame
[Applause]
live with you I think they do do it for
the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not really attention so you can
kind of do a cheat code you can go get a
BBL get a nice body and you do get more
attention from them than if you're flat
right but here's the thing though no no
but but listen though if it goes so
deeper though because I know who you're
talking about and she has a great body
yeah so you got to think about how far
down deep that she is within watching
the Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazines
great body it doesn't look good to a man
but you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest unders for women for women
so like the women have higher beauty
standards to me yes and that's what's
making women feel like they need to
comply with these standards who's
pickier men or women men and women are
more complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all them and yeah I think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 certainly but they will not marry
they will not settle down with somebody
with a fake or lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last but I I done
an only fans but it wasn't like vagina
boobs it was lingerie yeah builds right
whatever I'd done it and when I finished
it I felt very degraded I felt very like
why did I actually do that now I know
there's girls out there who do that they
don't feel that way that is perfectly
fine you do you you feel the way you
feel but me personally like like in the
future how like when I have kids and all
in the future and if my kids found out
about that they'll probably get bullied
in school there are people like oh your
mom doing this your mom doing that and
your man as well he's not going to if
you don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not a high
respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in and make sure you subscribe as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first announcement is that
we have two clips channels just Pearl
eclipse and pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both also guys we have four
membership tiers the first tier lets you
be a part of the live chat tonight
second tier um you get to be a part of
our discords and our Vlogs um if you
want to see me freestyle rap sign up for
the second tier we're also gonna do a
penthouse tour
um on the second tier I know I've been
promising that forever but it's coming I
swear
um third tier you get to connect with me
on social media and fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
how do you get a million subscribers in
a year I will tell you um also guys
um I can tell you how to do a live show
when it comes to recruiting
um production all that stuff so make
sure you sign up for that also guys they
took away my first Instagram um so go
follow just probably things one
um oh I just lost my fifth Tick Tock I'm
so sad
um so go yeah I lost my first second
third fourth and fifth so go follow my
six but they gave me my first username
back the first one I lost so go follow
just pearly I'm just excited I got it
back
[Applause]
I'm almost 2 000 followers on that so
get me to a thousand okay
um we're on Rumble so go follow Rumble
um also guys go subscribe to wife school
um we have two episodes coming out one
is what to cook for your husband in a
day and the other episode is how to
knead bread so you know if you want to
know how to need bread
[Music]
uh so guys we have a Google form make
sure you sign up for our Meetup we had a
meet-up in downtown London with all the
fans it was a lot of fun a couple weeks
ago we may even do a little concert type
thing so make sure you um sign up for
that um with some of the musicians that
have been on the show uh also guys we
have an animation Channel just pearly
animations
um how many likes blessing today do we
need to open up the chat we'll let
blessing decide drum roll everyone drum
roll drum roll drum roll 1.5 1.5 all
right 1.5
000 likes to open up the chat he's got
some high standards just like modern
women today evolving
um
okay that is all my announcements um
welcome to the show guys to start we are
going to say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself
yeah you got it you got it okay so
starting here go around and then second
row I'm Steph I'm 24. and I'm African
off Iranian but I live in London since
five years okay relationship status oh
it's like a single right
my name is Gemma Natalia fun fact about
me I am South African and Portuguese
and yes relationship status single
butthole
and what else let's see uh fun fact yeah
Age Two 27 yeah
Portuguese South African and I'm a
musician
hey
um abla Davis
um 39 years old
um fun facts about me I love doing music
um quite active so it's kind of hard I
do a lot of things
um my main focus is money so yeah don't
really like boys but all right
so single and hello good evening I am
just leash I am 34. I'm from London uh
fun fact about me is I am a radio
broadcaster I am a host and a presenter
I'm also in Property Management
Development I've got kids I wear many
many hats and um and I show up looking
all right
um go ahead and then we'll do second row
so go ahead yeah
um my name is Ty Logan I'm 25 years old
I'm from London my family backgrounds
Jamaican
um fun fact to my actor and Entertainer
and I've got freckles
you gotta tell them about our episode
yeah I'm sorry I'm both doing too much
you got it they gave me the Brandy I
shouldn't have done the brand you got it
you gotta do your fun facts yeah what do
we do this week yeah this week literally
yesterday yeah me and pearly linked up
and we've done a great interview show
she jumped to my new show tied talks and
she spilled the beans yeah literally I
think videos are going mad already yeah
they're on it I was like they're 24
hours
look out for that as well I was there
was definitely had and that's on
standout okay okay yeah I think it'll be
out this Sunday this Sunday okay
hi everyone my name is Sugar Puff
um I'm 31 years old
sugar pie yeah it's because I'm a puff
on the outside and sweet in the inside
should use that interesting fact about
me I see my tick tocks before I film
them so I can get anyone to film me
because I see them so I just direct it I
get strangers to film them sometimes so
that's an interesting fact pearly I'm
loving what you're wearing today very
That 70s Show and you're looking
stunning thank you happy to be on your
show
um then this way and then go around so
you start no pressure hey guys I am
Dimitri tukshar I am 40 years old and
today relationship statuses my and my
wife's 10-year wedding anniversary so we
had a wonderful day
can we just get a little more Applause
uh fun fact about me so I fit in this
crowd in a weird way I'm a chief
executive officer for a multinational
called lgbg fashion house which is a
bespoke suit company uh one thing that
people know about me is there's a lot of
these Jordan Peterson suits that are
going around being very famous and viral
right now I'm the guy that put those
together for him
um so that's something people know me
for
what tell them about our suit well so
actually I love Pearl's content I think
your content is awesome you know being
40 and married I think I am from the old
school I didn't think I was but now I'm
looking at your content I'm like this is
cool stuff so I reached out to Pearl I
said I really want to make you some like
real cool 1950s housewife type suits you
know like skirt suits like that color
that's the first one like knee length
skirt pencil skirt jacket like looking
classy right because she's classy
um and I just thought you know what like
she's up and coming she's gonna be she's
gonna be she's big now she's gonna be
huge and I want our brand to be a part
of that ride so here I am yes I'm gonna
get a suit soon I'm excited lucky
YouTuber lucky you
um go ahead hi guys I'm kiril I sell
suits for a living fun fact about me is
I love wrestling and I've been in a
long-term relationship
okay oh wait sorry
is it me yes hi everyone I'm boo
um I am 37 uh fun fact about me I am a
mum I am also I'm a DJ
uh I'm a river
um I'm a lover not a fighter as well
um what's the other thing
name age relationship status oh and I'm
a new I'm in a new relationship
so
can you wait for her yeah
depending okay depending on the
person's wife so I felt like we've
covered this topic before you know what
I mean once or twice but I felt like why
not cover it again okay so my question
is do you care about the past uh when it
comes to your partner so I want I want
the women to also answer and the men yep
um so start here and go around
definitely you care yeah okay so what
what's too shady of a past for you
um it depends when a Monday is too
thirsty and like all the women's and are
on him and like he's not I like
individuals I like like something that
is private that no one's like touching
one you know so yeah I think that one
okay go ahead
I think um
the truth for me is that you know
you obviously wanna
accept that that person has a past just
like you ever passed but in my youth in
my youth club in church when I was there
in high school it was every saint has a
pass in every sin has a future so I
think that you kind of have to think of
it in that way and like look at that
person as yourself in a way because it's
like I have a past we all have a past I
know I have a future I'm trying to live
in the present with this person so so
you don't care as much it's not about
caring or not because of course I care
but does it faze me that's the question
it doesn't is it really gonna bother us
every day okay we're gonna work it out
if that's the person I choose okay cool
what about you
um the past is definitely a concern well
it would be if there's a lot of baggage
coming from that past
um you know because it can get confusing
if a man has like five baby mothers a
girl what about three can you get away
with three
you could do one or no I might can you
could do one yeah two two yes or no
what if their Ex-Wives is that different
well Ex-Wives are different in it
because much different I think yeah
wait why is XYZ different to the baby
moms
because okay wait they were married
before they had the kid yeah
yeah but are we gonna continue or we're
gonna stick onto that one well I was
gonna I just was curious if it's
different to you well no
um with her ex-wife it's kind of it's
gone into a legal bind so if they
legally you know parted it's like okay
yeah all right that's fine so two
Ex-Wives you could two Ex-Wives with
kids you could deal with the two baby
mamas it's enough it's drama because you
know well there's drama either way yeah
he might be paying child support you
know I would say with the baby mom the
the baby dad would go to the flat and
sleep on the sofa what do you mean he's
sleeping on the sofa
have you experienced this yes
[Laughter]
so wait you were dating so you were
dating a guy yeah and then he said I'm
gonna go sleep on my baby mother's sofa
what does that even mean you know she's
homeless
foreign
sofa I don't think the ex-wife would
don't do that because I feel like the
ex-wife would kind of have somebody
there because he sent ex husband X so
you you feel like in a way you're kind
of saying like the ex-wife has more
value than that than the baby mama maybe
maybe because there was in a contract
binded and if they depart from that
contract you know
he's probably stuff that he has to pay
for the house so he ain't gonna go to
the sofa is he what about if if the guy
so if the guy is paying um child support
on his two kids yeah is that it was that
could that be a deal breaker for you no
no that lets me know that he's very
supportive and you know well what if he
has to live a really Frugal lifestyle
because of it that's what I'm saying
like like he spends more he spends more
on the on the two kids I don't mind
because at least you're looking out for
the own but I'm a bit I love going out I
love doing stuff I love the high life
and everything so if you got two baby
mothers and you've got child support to
pay babe where am I coming into this how
are we gonna make this happen you know
what I mean and it's It's Tricky like
who who you know I couldn't I don't
think I could and I've I've just walked
away from it so many times like okay I
can deal with the one baby mom and I can
see this wait wait wait you said times
how many how many baby fat like no no
I'm wow I'm thinking when I was a bit
younger okay when I'm dating in that
time but my now time now now okay so now
kids are off the table not
okay
okay it depends on the matter though
okay okay so for the right guy how many
baby moms could he have
the right guy whatever okay but not two
not two not two but two Ex-Wives he
could have one ex-wife One X okay
because that lets me know how much his
pocket is spending out okay you know
okay uh what about you what do you think
about past bit yes mattering yeah
um no I don't think someone's past
matters for me I don't think a man's
past matters
um I think if he's bringing baggage from
his past then that's something that
would have to be addressed and
everything's Case by case but if we're
talking about like you're not bringing
no baggage you've just been a hoe and
now we're doing relationship I don't
think I was judging money what if he
slept with one of your friends but it
was it was just a casual one night I
think I think number one
um if the if it was if it was just like
a one-night stand thing I don't care so
who who here out of the girls if you
slept with one of your friends you could
you could get over it nope I would you
could either get over here
one time one time so I would say if like
he couldn't have just slept with my
friend last month and now he's trying to
talk to me about XYZ I would have to
assess how my friend feels about that
there would be factors to it but if it
was there was no strings attached they
both just had a fling they had a
one-time thing there was no feeling in
the situation
okay so you you you're saying no she
said yes she said yes what do you say uh
I think that if there's betrayal in
anything then you know things always
you're just left with I now have to
react okay it wasn't about trailers what
was the for me that I knew yeah yeah
you're you're finding out this is you
know know the guy he's in your circle
whatever he's a good guy that's the
thing he slept with her a year ago
friends right it just happened to happen
one night and you weren't even thinking
about yeah yeah so you could get over it
you could get over it that's cool but he
wouldn't be able to get over it I get
that like men wouldn't be able to get
over us doing that today oh
we'll find out okay what do you think
could you get over it
um not really because I wouldn't even go
to like my men's friend and like be with
him so it's the same thing okay it's the
same thing okay uh you have stronger but
go ahead go ahead go ahead strong
opinion wow right which where should I
start on firstly if it was with my
friend that's a negative no no no never
no no because how are we shooting no
we're not sharing the same nah
[Music]
you're sharing no she went there first
and then I'll be gone there yeah and
that's my friends and then that's all
too much there's a lot of men out there
yeah I'm all right I'll keep it moving
yeah and back to the baguette of the
past for me
the only thing that really would really
go for me in the park with a man's past
is
if there's a history because you see you
see when geezers are like oh yeah my ex
is crazy but my other ex is crazy but my
other ex is crazy
right that's when it's like yeah that's
when I care about your past because I'm
like how either you just meet all crazy
women or you're turning them all crazy
has that happened to you before yes yes
oh yes how what happened yeah everyone
was crazy apparently
[Laughter]
he just told a lot of lies you know when
you just telling a lot of lies and make
it and this is when and he went for
younger girls as well so they were a bit
more naive and it was like he told him
lies and turned more lies and then the
lies caught up with him and then he then
it was he'd keep it moving he'd be like
yeah she's crazy she's crazy and I'm
like yeah no you've met the real crazy
now so oh so you were the real crazy
yeah I'm the real crazy so then what did
you do what did you do I said bye oh
that's it yeah that doesn't sound crazy
but apparently I've heard of I've heard
I am crazy oh so now he's saying you're
crazy it's not one of them it's a little
pattern that that's what I mean but if
he slept around or anything that you
don't care like if he slept if he was he
had a whole phase for like I think all
men have had a whole face I don't know
about that one in three men are under 30
or their virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
yeah no but um I mean do you think the
guy at Tesco is really getting laid
yeah yeah but then there's certain oh no
let me know
go through go through no cause I was
gonna say you think you're saying that
the certain man at Tesco you think
there's not certain girls who would do
anything to just to get that bit of
attention I think if the guys are good
looking maybe yeah but like women women
find 80 of men as unattractive so not
not okay not average looking like ugly
wow think about it
that is that is a good point yeah like
what I mean
all right I just have a question I have
a question I have a question out of the
women other women who here would
describe themselves as picky
I like certain things but I wouldn't say
like I have a very strict type on paper
that if you don't meet this requirement
I won't look at you yeah
I don't I don't really know what what to
really to say on that because well what
what do you what do you look for in a
guy like what are your what are your
requirements are pretty eyes no
honestly it's
I thought oh how can I say it's got to
be kind of like quite an Alfrey kind of
meal it's more it's not so much just the
looks obviously look you can't be ugly
because that's that's just yeah that's
just never gonna work really silly I've
got to be attracted to you but you've
got to be kind of an alpha really
because I'm quite I'm quite now for
female you're not you're an alpha female
yeah
why because that's what I don't know
that's what I've been told
people so you believe what other people
say about you then oh no well I'm just
saying I'm just saying things I've been
told do you think Alpha Man like yeah
Alpha females don't Alpha men like want
submissive females but then Alpha
females can be submissive to the right
alpha male or to the right man
yeah but you don't think there's a line
of men waiting today or women waiting to
date Alpha men like why would they deal
with an alpha female because they wanted
men don't want to date themselves
actually but no but then that's the
difference between a male and a female
because maybe then she'll submit because
she's good she'll give him the same run
for his money and keep his mind going
yeah but why would a guy go through that
when he could just go to a girl that
doesn't something exactly why do men
cheat
someone like that and so yeah some men
like to be taken care of as well yep
yeah I mean we can talk about exceptions
no no but that's what I'm saying because
an alpha female would still she could
she can still provide it she can still
she can still she can still hold it down
so maybe she can hold it down for him
instead of him always happens yeah guys
don't care about your money not in
general I didn't say money I didn't say
money
holding it down emotionally if you
remember because it's a lot for a man to
especially an alpha man to offload his
emotions onto somebody to show his
vulnerability I do believe that with an
alpha female he will do that because he
knows she can hold it down and she could
take it on board and not use it against
him that's what I just said that's what
I believe I think I know what she means
as well okay explain I feel like well in
terms of alpha female tell me if I'm
wrong go on I feel like when you say
alpha female you know there's some man
out there they like a girl that I'll
give them a beer
so in between the age 25 to 40
most men yeah I like that I'm not saying
they want that but there's a there's a
percentage of them men that like the
alpha female yeah they like a bit of
fight back do you think it's the
majority no it's not it's a minority
it's a minority but that man no reason
yeah but I found that's like more like
men that are like more feminine okay
I agree no I don't agree I feel like no
I I disagree I think
I've I've I haven't traveled to many
places but what I can say is being in
South Africa being in Florida and being
here in the UK
there will always be that kind of man
that wants that kind of woman and yes
they want the submissive woman but it's
like why do you have to be submissive in
public when you are who you are you are
who you are I am who I am what do you
mean why do you have to be submissive in
public can you explain that more it's
like some guys are happier when their
woman's just sitting next to them and
just smiling and not talking to any men
and not looking at any men's Direction
like not talking to females not talking
because your draw out you're gonna you
know like so and do you think that's a
problem I think when a when a high value
man brings along a goal in public I
think that this a particular woman that
he brings with has to be quite reserved
so can I just say something in in terms
of the minority so that's that's like
you know that's is that that's your
definition of submissive
just sitting there quietly and not
saying a word well no what I'm saying is
I didn't mean like sitting quietly and
not saying a word I just said reserved
but being seen and not heard yeah but in
a way where I don't have to talk because
my man's doing all the talking bad the
problem is when you meet the phony ones
who do too much talking and then you're
just sitting there like I think I've
submitted I think of submitting to
Authority like so so when you have a job
so when you have a job right you know if
you're if your boss says do this yeah
you don't spend an hour arguing well why
are we doing this like why do I have to
do this like no you just say okay and
you do it yeah so that's what I think of
when I think I submissive that's what
that's what I think that's what I think
that's what I think for sure
but then it can be also like the way
they say you can say it so do that so so
when I think what I'm saying is I don't
think sorry I don't think that those men
are
like
feminine they're not feminine you know
what I mean which ones the ones who
choose the alpha alpha women yeah you're
able to hold conversations when they're
not around babe I'm going to the toilet
cool I'm gonna have conversations while
you go to the right but it's not about
Converse it's not about conversations
it's about listening so I just think
those men they usually have hard jobs
they work a lot they work long hours and
they don't typically want a woman that's
not going to listen and Alpha I've just
found that Alpha women don't tend to
listen like it's my way or the highway
I'm the alpha I'm the leader because
what's an alpha that's a leader a leader
you can't have two leaders in a
relationship why would a guy that's a
leader want another leader yeah you can
do because
that's what we mean because at the end
of the day like someone has to make a
decision I don't think there's one
destination though I think this if
you're talking about being in a
relationship and having family there's
two Destiny there's a few destinations
that come together what are those when
you say destinations like as the woman
in the family like the mother she needs
to take care of the children take care
of the house the man and lead them and
Lead when he's not around but when he's
around
there's that sense of okay I can chill
for a second yeah but not a lot of men
can back that up I feel like I feel like
there might be some sort of like
misconfusion everyone's missing each
other yes
when you're saying different paths yeah
there's one woman that's gonna listen
sit back all right babes even if she's
got her opinion she's not gonna say it
yep because she just wants to just make
her man happy and get on with it and
have a happy marriage then you've got
the other woman that can be a leader
just like her husband however they're
both bosses and they come together as a
team thank you
I know many relations he's not
submissive but she's just understanding
she's got her Point as well they're
gonna come together at the end and
they're gonna meet at the final but
can't submit when it's when it's needed
that makes sense it never makes sense
not really could you could you give me
an example of that I think I know I know
what you mean okay I can give you an
example then Jay-Z and Beyonce Beyonce
she's a leader she's a boss she's an
independent woman the biggest Capper
because she's talking about he doesn't
need a man when she you know you know
it's music
but that's what I'm saying she's she's
busy brainwashing these babies
when her when she caught Jay-Z cheating
was she an alpha female or did she say
you know what I mean no way she was an
alpha because she was like do you know
what bridgen I'm submit to that one
actually but maybe
what you were saying so as I said as I
made my point some women are
understanding remember we spoke about
the other day pearly some men if you're
in the entertainment business
you know what the guy's gonna cheat
she's understanding am I gonna throw
away this Legacy I'm gonna throw away
this business or should I just get up
with it and throw it along you know what
I'm trying to say I'm not saying that
she's not a leader and a boss but I'm
saying there's some women that can be a
leader in the boss and the understanding
don't mean that they're not submissive
yeah you know what I'm saying the whole
situation on lemonade like I believe
when once I came out with that lemonade
album yeah I believe everybody said no
to their boyfriend and they ran away
from her boyfriend and then she was like
I'm pregnant with twins I was like
I'll bring out the lemonade
for following celebrities I've just
never I've never met a girl that calls
herself an alpha female yeah I really
believe it's submissive in a
relationship yeah yeah I think that
people take the word Alpha do you think
women can actually be Alpha females
to me no no no let's get into it please
because I need to understand I'll let
you yeah if you want it to me an alpha
woman can be a very strong woman who
just got her [__] together tell him
again and she knows how to take care of
her man she does her thing and she she
gets on with life and yeah she's a
strong woman she can do a bit of DIY she
can do everything you know I I've got
four sisters and let me tell you all my
four sisters can do more than me so can
I including DIY everything they can do
everything because they we I grew up in
a big family where my sisters had to
basically defend themselves and and they
grew up in the 90s in in White Chapel
green so it was a time where you had to
be strong you had to
stand up for yourself you would say
they're more modern than traditional yes
but like what has better outcomes
if the modern Alpha females had good
outcomes why are men getting their
passports and leaving a woman
because more time one minute more time
if you ask most of these men they were
brought up by a single mom wait hold on
so would they say that their mum was not
an alpha I just that's just what I'd
like to throw out because I'm sure if
they were raised by a woman who had to
hold it down for their whole family and
look after them and bring them all up so
it sounds to me like she sounds like
she's a bit so but so she was raised by
a woman that doesn't know how to how to
have a functional relationship who said
she doesn't know how to because she
couldn't if she's a single mother she
doesn't know how to have a functionality
because those are the results
man you failed the test but oh I got it
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
so wait no wait wait so yeah so she
doesn't know how to function how to have
a functional relationship because
the the father of the child decided so
he he was like no he decided I don't
want to be a dad and he walked out on
the child so she doesn't and she doesn't
know yeah because women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 of them no no no
no I'm just saying so she doesn't know
so you're just the same because she
doesn't she doesn't she she either
picked someone like I mean come on why
would you have a kid with someone that
isn't gonna stick around well
there are some men who will get a few
baby mamas and they'd visit one from
another and they kind of set up their
lives so there are men who do that and
because the women are getting financed
or they're getting support they're fine
with it because they're living their
lives yeah but this is accepted like you
guys keep talking about exceptions I'm
talking about the rule the majority of
men don't have multiple baby mothers yes
one out of three men are either virgins
are having had sex in the past we're
talking about the rule not the exception
and I think a lot of girls will continue
to talk to these men even though they
know they have multiple babies
so we go back to your question your
question which is can't do single
mothers know how to have a functional
relationship no no I didn't say that
usually no you you asked if that's what
I would say yeah and I'm saying I stand
on that no in general no other
exceptions not many no no
yeah
I'll be real though I'll be real come
see me like it depends it depends on
your environment yep your background the
community you've been raised on yes to
what you will see and what you will
visualize yes so we might see something
different to what you see and sign us to
what you see but I'll be real I don't
know if it's a small jury it's like what
because I know a lot of people are
single moms or fellow my friends
okay if they're single mothers okay it's
like if you're okay if I'm applying for
a job all right and I say that job I
failed that job I failed that job I also
failed how can I say I did the job well
when you ask a job and well I think that
we're overlooking as well is no by no
means does any woman and can any woman
predict the outcome of their
relationship right or if the man's gonna
stick around or if I have a kid with
this guy is he going to stay with me is
he going to marry me but what women do
do is we Overlook red flags
everything's not everybody but a lot of
women don't listen a lot of men don't
listen but if we're just talking about
this for a moment women make choices
that they know are not the right choices
when they know that it's not the right
man
reason number one reason number one okay
when you take your marriage vows it's
supposed to be for Better or For Worse
for sicknesses and health not if I don't
feel happy today I I we fell out of love
and I lost myself what happened to For
Better or For Worse what happened to in
sickness
for stupid reasons
one of the number one indicators of
divorces if a woman will start out
earning her man
and she puts a financial gain above her
kids that's a stupid reason yeah thank
you what kind of women can we talk about
statistics how many people are married
fifty percent Americans aren't in
divorce so half half well has anyone
married have you been married have you
been married have you been married
oh yes
if we're talking now on the spectrum of
25 to 40 yeah in that range at age range
then obviously like we can talk about
the things of the woman has to do what
she does in the madness please just
re-up on what you said because my ADHD
is going a bit wild which part which
ones you had oh I said women divorce for
stupid reasons right so free reasons why
do why do women okay
I'm invested in this now when women are
dating in their 20s and 30s right I can
speak obviously for 20s
um
you know the thing is you give people
chances
I'm not trying to find the perfect man
who does nothing wrong no because I do
okay well I feel it
I want to dissect wait wait I wasn't
finished
on that side yeah don't want to leave
but then now you're saying why do women
leave right and their woman their
reasons are stupid for leaving yeah have
you heard about this thing called
intuition now potentially it could just
be [__] crazy sorry
it could be crazy but at the end of the
day like we know that women have more
connection to certain things if they
haven't been on contraception for years
and they haven't been eating all the
garbage that they've been eating and
drinking all the gin and doing all of
those things it desensitizes the human
connecting to the Earth so I'm just
saying intuition's a real thing okay
yeah but you know what I mean but yeah
that's like women feel different
intuition tuition every other week based
on where we are in our cycle one week
so it's like I'll talk to a girl one
week and she hates her boyfriend and
then the next week she's in love with
her boyfriend
so I actually feel sorry for their
boyfriend because I'm like he probably
doesn't know whether he's coming or
going something like this
10 seconds I love him so much but he's
done this I'm like this darling I'm
already tired I don't know about your
boyfriend but I'm tired I'm out and then
we'll go guys
those guys the guys that under intuition
it's like that's what guys don't do it
again I read something so interesting
the other day so basically you know when
women have these contraceptive things on
their arms yeah apparently it changes
your hormone so imagine if you meet
someone no [__] and it's been found
recently
um basically if you're on these pills
conceptive pills and you meet someone
and then you get married and all of a
sudden you go off of them and then a
patent the hormone Center you're not
attracted to your partner so that is a
lot of the things that's happening
around the world now yeah
I'm messing people's lives up they are
ruining girls and thousands
and whose fault is that who took it
women
who's the one who takes the actual semen
that either way is gonna have a baby or
an abortion so but what do you
[Music]
what are you if it breaks and you don't
know
then you know maybe sleep with people
that you want to have kids with but then
yeah
wait wait
wait
wait let me just take him back to that
point but super sleep with people you
might want to have kids with but what
but you remember you said but then
you've got to pick him to make sure he's
the one who's not going to leave I mean
you could you could waste it you could
you could wait to have sex you could you
could wait till you don't you could do
her head and say you have to sleep with
these men no you don't
do anything
you just don't ever have sex live like a
nun
you could wait you could wait to get
married before you have a child question
okay can I can I is it time to drop some
red pills into the sangria yeah go ahead
yes are we ready to spike yeah where's
the blue pill well
so the question was does your potential
partner or partner's past matter yes can
I share my opinion on this one all right
sorry guys sorry what's your what's
jargon haven't said nothing yet so
uh here let's let's let's do Let's do
let's do some uh let's do some lessons
in genetics and biology because we can
refer to our trusty friends uh from the
Gregor Mendel book of biology we
understand DNA do we not yes if you look
in your family tree this is
statistically accurate you have twice as
many women in your family tree as you
have men you have twice as many women in
your family tree as men why what does
that mean
what does that mean women give birth and
there's more of them they're meant to
multiply yeah yeah what it means is that
a vast majority of women have babies
with the same men meaning what that
means the reason you have twice as many
women is a small percentage of men about
20 percent of men basically created all
of us Genghis Khan Genghis Khan has his
DNA in something like
180 million people today does that mean
he's been sleeping around bears in the
past life what it means let me explain
it it's a very simple thing but the
question was does a partner's past
matter what it says is very
what it says is very clear that women
continuously choose the men that other
women choose that's what it means we
know you know what we know this we know
the statistic from dating apps right 80
of men have absolutely no prospects of
sex or dating at all because you can
look at the Tinder data 80 of men get
zero matches ever one percent of men are
like Genghis Khan levels so there's a
person's past matter if you look at the
science it clearly matters that women
want to choose men that have had the
most partners because that's who they
keep choosing all the time wow so that
might not be an emotional argument
that's just statistics it's a fact
okay can I say that from the other side
how men look at this argument okay from
a men's perspective it's a little
different so I'm in the business of
effectively like our company LGBT we
sell high-end bespoke suits we go to
Executive offices so we meet rich men
all the time really what I do is I
recruit young men and women to sell to
very high net worth people okay and this
is a conversation for young men I'm
going to say this to the young guys out
there here's a question what is a man
really doing with his life to increase
his value we can measure it you know
what the number the answer is what does
a man measure in value what do we
measure
that's money it's just money right if
they so here's a question does a man
have any incentive to It is Well
influenced effectively to transmit that
into money and by the way influence and
fame are very highly correlated to how
many sexual partners a man has access to
so you're saying the same thing I just
want the guy that every other woman
wants that's what you're saying but
you're not saying it okay so does a man
have any incentive to increase his value
through financial gain does a man have
that incentive yes okay do women want to
be wealthy too like you girls you're all
going to be 61 there you say I want to
retire do you want to have something to
retire with of course okay so here's
here's the here's a statistic the
typical retired married man
average but not typical average the
numbers of course there's a big gap but
the average married man retires with
about six hundred thousand US dollars in
savings 600 000 the average divorced
single man
this is the statistic retires with a
hundred thousand okay the average
divorced and remarried man retires at
about 400 000. so the outcome of staying
and getting married has a significant
impact on a man's value and status and
ultimately his comfort in life so the
question therefore is does the spouse
you choose matter yes why does it matter
yes we can actually measure with money
that it literally like we have a number
that we can look at and says yes the
spouse issues matters okay well a
psychologist will tell you there's two
ways to ruin your life number one become
an alcoholic number two marry an
alcoholic well here's a question what's
the problem with Marrying an alcoholic
ladies and gentlemen impulse control
impulse control How's that gonna impact
that they're going to be talking rubbish
and no one will understand this and
they're gonna kids and all sorts of
craps so the question is would you marry
an alcoholic and say no I won't why not
because the chance of divorce are much
higher so does a woman's past matter
okay well let's say a woman had a lot of
sexual partners does that indicate any
sort of I don't know does that have any
impact on her pair bonding ability
yes well we know that it does okay so if
I if you marry a hoe because that let's
just go right to the core here that's
the question right yeah that's the
question yeah so if you do that are your
chances of divorce higher well she's got
lower pair bonding she's got lower
impulse control she's not a strategic
thinker because she knows impulsively
and intuitively that she's reducing her
value so when I coach a young guy that
we hire into our company we don't just
look at their job we look at their life
plan and we want to be I have two more
stats real quick we want to be strategic
and we want to optimize for success and
mitigate for risk are you mitigating for
risk if you're not looking at a woman's
past you're creating yourself an
opportunity for failure by the way
here's a question guys what percentage
of millionaires are married
I'm getting married
I'm not the rich ones she as well okay
85 so the question is let's let's look
into that like we're asking again those
are Partners past matter why is it that
80 minutes
you want you want that or you don't want
that if you don't want that I know it's
hard to hear you don't want to hear it's
just facts thank you no honestly it's
interesting to learn so thank you so
much guys guys do you guys do you guys
think that for a man to become a
millionaire he has to be a strategic
thinker yes do you think no no no yes he
does so you think so you think the
statistically millionaires are less
strategic or equally
I think millionaires it depends on have
you born have you been born into wealth
time I've been given I was born into the
Soviet Union I grew up on food stamps
okay so um I guess yeah it doesn't
matter but some people some millionaires
in like privileged families don't do
anything we're just looking at
statistics every rule has a rule breaker
again mitigate for risk so it's like if
you want to bet all your money on you
know 20 black on the roulette and you're
like I'm gonna make a billion dollars
yeah some people made a million dollars
rolling that most people lose everything
they ever had it's bad risk mitigation
we're talking about statistics right so
it's like if the partner that you choose
matters to the outcome of your life you
have to be strategic about it so does it
matter well the numbers clear indicated
matters
no you can be delusional you can say
well it shouldn't matter okay can so you
you make suits for um High net worth
clients can you tell me about the women
they pick as wives yeah so first of all
do they pick Alpha females when I no
absolutely not uh so so here let me tell
you guys I had my dinner last night with
my wife it was her 10th anniversary and
she said my wife said something really
profound right like it kind of shocked
me a little bit is I said you know it's
so much fun like building a life with
you I told her at so much fun built we
got four kids I'm like it's so much fun
building a life with you because I've
had a great 10 years right and she goes
oh I didn't get in here to build I
wanted a ride on this train oh that's so
sad that's what she said
she's gonna be rude because honest
though um
again well let's let's look at it like
the Simon London today I fly back on
Saturday I live in Estonia on Wednesday
I take off to Dubai on Saturday I'm in
moderate India the next one the next
Wednesday I'm in New Delhi I am in
demand because I'm I'm a successful dude
and you know what all successful dudes
are in demand they're not sitting at
home smoking pot man they're doing
they're getting calls they're doing
stuff and you know what they're needed
they're needed because it's hard to find
competency good people yeah you know
what you're doing all these where's your
wife and the kids at home actually
that's not true so I'll tell you right
now
um uh earlier this year I took my whole
family where do we go no no I mean I
mean just when you're working just now
you know the places we've got to go so
in between how much did you see the what
do you quite often I bring my whole
family on my trips
are they homeschool
oh no they're going to like an English
college but like so like that last year
January we had a video shoot in Hawaii I
took my wife my wife and four kids to
Hawaii uh after that we had a company
trip to Croatia I took my whole family
with me no no so I'm just saying so you
know in the past couple of days in the
next few days that you said the only
places you're going to so
it's your anniversary today well yeah
and so have you been with your wife
today yeah yeah so and then you're going
when you when's your next trip I come
back in three days back home and then
I'm home for three days and then I take
off for another week and a half okay
yeah because you know when you the way
you said it I was like okay so that's
what I was sort of wondering so that's
when you get so that's when you get to
see wife and the kids in that I see my
wife and kids all the time okay can you
tell me more about that like what traits
do men um in that position look for well
the thing the thing about it like I
don't want to over generalize but there
is definitely a trend so I'll tell you
guys this is a story I tell all the time
I've met a lot of dudes whose wife is
just not getting deed down or something
because she's like right like it's like
but here's the thing let me tell you
guys about I've worked with clients that
I've worked with clients for real that
are world class musicians and movie
stars that are household names that
everybody knows like right and I've been
asked this before on on uh somebody
asked me like is there any difference
between like the wife of this really
famous musician and this really famous
movie star to the wife of just a regular
dude like yes their wife's wives are the
most supportive the happiest like I'll
deliver a suit to some Average Joe and
his wife saying anything makes them look
fat I'm like no you don't like your
husband but when I deliver like for I
mean I remember I'll tell you guys an
Alice Cooper story like the musician his
wife like she came in and she's like you
look amazing he's 75 years old he's he's
old he's like you look amazing that's so
perfect like wow look at the energy that
she was just so and every single
extremely famous person I've been with
like that but was it real yes their
wives I mean there's a respect aspect to
it but like man well I'm thinking this
dude's 75 years old he's still torn by
the way it's like he doesn't have time
to come home and put up with like
weirdness you know what I mean and I
think she knows but she knows that
because that's why she would do it
because obviously he's going to keep it
moving and then obviously the money's
gonna stop uh I don't know the answer to
that I'm I'm sorry I was asked an
anecdotal experience like when I'm
dealing with
successful
um ultimately they're very very busy
like they're you know these are like
almost all successful men are a type men
like they're up in the morning they're
working their butts off like when you
think about this is a really interesting
point that I've noticed by the way you
can cut me off at any time
um you would think like oh he's rich but
he has to be unhappy or he's he's got
this great job but he should but he's
just like unfit no success goes with
success like the best looking people are
the ones that make the most money
everything goes together so these guys
like they're the ones in the gym in the
morning they look amazing they're so
sharp and you know I've I've gone down
the street with some of my clients like
hey let's grab a coffee whatever and I'm
walking down the street and I see the
women's eyes just gravitate towards
these guys because the woman knows when
she sees a high value man and by the way
we just established that women
continuously choose men that other women
pick we know this genetically right and
so I you know if a guy like that is well
first of all is he more strategic than
picking his wife yes everything in his
life has planned out your dad Pearl is
like a really successful guy I'm sure
he's really strategic in the way he
makes decisions is he not yeah he's very
strategic and I'm sure you saw a lot of
that growing up like he would just be
like okay pro and con let's go
um yeah every time every time I cry
about a business problem I call my dad
and he fixes it for me
it's not a life
problems
anything that goes wrong oh my God I'm
like that yeah
because daddy that's what that is that's
what daddies do therefore
that's what I mean men don't want to
deal with Alpha females though because
like the men like that like I'm thinking
I'm thinking wait I'm thinking of my dad
right and he he is so logical he is so
logical that like and and me when I when
I have a business problem or whatever I
get so stressed out sometimes I'll like
cry like I'll just be like and I'll call
him and he's so good at just like okay
what is the problem
what is the problem this is like okay
here's one solution here's two solutions
but like men like that they don't want
to have a girl that's constantly arguing
with them
that might not be what you meant but
typically that's what all alcohol
because what what is it what is an alpha
that's a leader yeah so so how how is in
that situation I mean that's that's like
family but in that situation
always pig-headed leaders you don't know
me like it's my way of the highway uh
yeah but at the end of the day like they
want to know that you trust them to make
a decision so they don't want they don't
want to hear like why like one thing I
didn't understand about men is like when
you say why to them it's like annoying
it is like they're like why is he doing
this
you know when you do that why why
because I [__] said so yeah yeah that
one not every two seconds why sometimes
but sometimes I mean it's when they ask
why sometimes it's all because well but
when the wires keep coming and the wires
keep coming it's because I said so in it
yeah but that's the point so that's why
because what is an alpha that's a leader
so the leader is the one that that's
saying this is where we should go this
is the problem yeah and so when I when I
speak to my dad like I have a really
good relationship with him because I
trust him yeah and because when he tells
me to do something for them I mean
sometimes sometimes I don't but for the
most part like I listen right but there
you go sometimes but then that's what I
mean yeah but usually when I don't
listen it doesn't work out and I'm like
I said yeah but we know that that that's
what happens but then it doesn't I think
I think it sometimes it's just a
perception that's I think that's maybe
another thing that's maybe another topic
the perception of an alpha on an alpha
and an alpha female and an alpha male
yeah I think that might be I think
there's different perceptions
but the question is why why do we have
those perceptions like we can't if if
the women that say I am an alpha female
have a reputation of something like
that's the alpha female's fault
like there's a reason they have that
reputation why is it going to be a fault
to be in an alpha female I mean I just
feel like everything in life is your own
fault so if you're if if they make an
assumption because you're an alpha
you're not going to be your own
greatness instead of your own food why
does he have to be well
in this situation it's because men don't
want it definitely because
I mean I don't know your personal
situation but typically the most
successful men with the most options
don't typically want Alpha females
because they're getting those options
because who wants who wants who wants a
woman who's just gonna but then certain
some more time as well you've got to
think the ones the ones who don't want
the alpha female they'll still go and
cheat you know
okay let me ask you guys a question do
you believe that successful people tend
to be more logical than unsuccessful
people in general are they more logical
or less logical they're more logical do
you guys all believe that I would say so
what does it mean to be logical Define
that
actually thinking and processing it and
thinking what's the best way to make a
decision okay that's what makes sense
I'll make I'll make it really simple
being logical simply means that you
value what you want most more than what
you value what you want right now yeah
okay what makes it okay so you're saying
like oh these guys all cheat I don't
know what kind of dudes you know and
they'd say
I mean I didn't say oh and also I don't
know
you said statistics but what what what
groups were involved in in doing this
Statistics
we're talking about successful men so
the what do you guys what is the typical
millionaire like that's an interesting
question what's the typical I probably
would say he waits for money five
o'clock in the morning
do they have a routine
and that filters across the whole of
their life it's not just in one specific
area they're logical they make decisions
that are good for the future versus now
that's correct does that make sense so
it's like so it's like there's a
significant amount of risk mitigation
it's like I understand what's happening
yeah there's some slime balls of course
but for the successful guys that are the
typical like logical calculating
Dependable are they Dependable yeah the
successful people have a lot of people
depend on them yeah if they mean what
they say well if you're a small business
owner you've got to be damn Dependable
like people you know because that's your
that's your livelihood so you're dealing
with a group that's dependable logical
strategic risk mitigating and and by the
way they get divorced way less like
millionaires you remember 90 yeah yeah
okay okay but a lot of millionaires
though they have a double life as well
wait wait wait wait wait wait guys guys
guys guys
stop stop stop okay
um out of how many millionaires do you
guys know a couple of them okay so how
how a few how much
okay okay well no I do guys
how close are you with them
one close-ish one close-ish okay what
does he do uh she she yeah okay so no no
male millionaires yeah the other one
okay what does he do
um he is in distribution
[Laughter]
property property development how many
millionaires you know on my on my two
hands like account okay how many oh yeah
property many I could see that yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um I used to date a multi millionaire
what do you have two Ex-Wives what
happened yeah what happened
to that one definitely but at the same
time like they say they live a double
life yeah I've seen it with my eyes he
was obviously he wasn't from here you
don't find much millionaires in the UK
and even if you do they're always like
they're from another country and they've
come here and they're traveling and
they're this and that and you know it
was dating for a long time so you don't
know any you know some you know some you
you know millionaires yes or no
one hand yeah you do uh it's not that a
northern but I met like five six of them
yeah I did and I've seen with my eyes
during double lives
for two three days
so what type of Industries are they in
uh lawyer like big lawyers the one there
like you know they're next to the judge
and like people you'll make them please
yeah yeah
um some producers of films so you go to
these After parties and and you see them
cheating there yeah okay so what do you
say to them well I I my company now has
over 15 000 clients over 95 of them I'm
sure our millionaires or above so 15 000
is a pretty good data set my question to
you guys would be offensive question
coming up
why are these duplicitous slimy
characters picking you in for what or
why are they picking the people in the
crowds you're hanging out with like what
kind of crowds are these like I'm not
well well
um
specific uh occasion that made me think
about them
you're changing what you said you did
yeah
the rest that I haven't seen it I know
because of my friends are friends
but then why are your friends involved
with them because there are uh how can I
say events in London there are so many
things going on in London and people
know people that's how you meet I've
seen too much and my heart broke
honestly I've seen so many people where
I've seen them like with their Partners
all happy and there's me making
conversations speaking with the wife
talking about kissing babies and all
that and then you see them when I see
the person one or the other cheating
secretly just breaks my heart but then
again sometimes people's always it's
normal as well where they have open
relationships so you also don't know but
I've yeah but being working in the media
industry for 10 years plus I've seen a
lot and I've crossed past many millions
but millionaires there's two obviously
I'm coming from the entertainment
industry aspect what I've seen but by
what um what's your name sir Reagan
Dimitri yeah what Dimitri was saying yes
there's also there's also a group of of
men that I know that are very loyal
because they need to protect their wife
is like their asset they need to protect
them and make sure they kind of amazing
we cannot say that like millionaires
they're not cheaters because they have
this this and that like that is that and
then like in life there is everything
yeah everything everything's like it's
not like oh because they're Millions
because they think logically uh because
they have a certain lifestyle they don't
do that because they are Saints that's
not like do you know what I mean see
it's it's interesting because I actually
I sort of see both sides on this because
like where I grew up cheating just
wasn't really that big to be honest um
where I grew up and I grew up in a
pretty like well-off Community but at
the same time the numbers don't support
you like at all um it's like the
cheating rate is one and this is just
self-admitted it's one out of four um
until you get over 250 000 then it up to
50 that's just self-admitted so it's
probably higher yeah 100 you know people
then like having their realities away
but what hold on but then it's like then
you ask the question how reliable is a
self-report you know
okay so go ahead go ahead and I just ask
have we moved on from that original
question
the way back
you get me because I feel like every
time I get my point across people say
I'm wrong but I feel like the past the
past is very important so I'm trying to
say yes some things build your character
some things are part of you yeah
it does I'm sorry because if I don't
wanna do I'm sorry
what you've done you've done so now what
I've got a pickup baggage I've got to
deal with luggage I'm sorry so yeah man
for me I don't judge anyone I've done a
video on myself
as a man's you love the hoes appreciate
the hoes nothing's wrong with them
nothing wrong with them
for me now but can you laugh marriage
there are some people who have been
through traumas and sex is there is
their way of coping
they're becoming a hole wait wait for
mental traumas all right I would like to
I'd like to just add one thing what I'm
hearing what I'm hearing here right here
wait wait
is an excuse no no no no no
no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
okay okay
who's in who's who's
ad-libbing there are some people that if
you if you read documents and all that
they get raped and all that they get
okay
they get graped and because I'm saying
grape I'm forgiving but but remember
they get great yeah so then they kind of
they feel depressed and they go through
a lot of things and they don't they
don't just they don't respect themselves
and that's when that comes is this the
exception or is it the rule no it's not
it's not an except now there's another
type of hole which they they know what
they're doing they're sleeping around
and they're happy just to live but
here's but here's the problem with even
the first how the world doesn't oh you
understand it yeah
there's some people that go through that
and don't make those choices
is like it's know the choice you made
and you can't whine about it
but pearly do you know what that's what
people underestimate but some people we
all we all have different Hearts we all
grow up differently we all go through
different experiences
no no but but as as human beings as
people we should be understanding
you can be understanding and treat them
with respect and politely but that
doesn't mean that other men have to date
and about some people actually heal some
people when they get loving kids
I have to be honest I have to be honest
with you before I started the show
um I really thought healing meant
something else I really thought when
women like healed they went to therapy
but I just found healing is like another
word for just sleeping around
they do some meditating and now
they're healed no yes no I don't think
really what's like I think healing works
with actually
self-reflecting challenging yourself and
think okay how can I how can okay I've
done this this wasn't very nice and you
self-reflect and you figure out how
you're gonna heal how you're gonna get
through how you're gonna to treat a
situation differently I do agree with
you there's there's learning from
experience right
um but it's like how many times you
gotta have the same experience before
you learn you know what I mean it's like
that one two three twenty Thirty forty
I've seen I don't know why but always
stranger girls come and talk to me and
they tell me their whole lives and and
what I find sad is and that's why I say
like it's so important for us as humans
to be understanding because
some people mentally they're not
beautiful so I as I think that we should
be less understanding yes no I think I
think I think okay I think it's good I
think it's good to be understanding when
it comes to Mental Health
I think that okay nowadays everybody's
got a mental health everybody everybody
I remember when oh you know what my
least favorite word is now trauma trauma
trauma used to be about war not your
ex-boyfriend cheating on you three times
the kids yeah that's what I say too but
now now this is my trauma I've gone
through trauma because my ex-boyfriend
no that's supposed to be cool because
she took me about three times so you're
the kids
[Laughter]
are you saying in most cases when people
talk about relationship trauma they're
only talking specifically about the
cheating
about experience the heartbreaking no
because you know
every minute
giving no pause no pause giving
but this is this is
what they say when you say giving when
you say giving okay one man up what
about woman up
men make more than women at large for a
lifetime men make more than women women
way more than men and they have higher
body counts than men women's
names
sorry sorry guys guys one person at the
time there's a lot of overtoking support
because at the end of the day so one
person at a time let the moderator pick
the person who's talking thank you one
out of three men are either versions or
have it had sex in the past year have
one out of three women are they virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
I couldn't it's a bit both
no I think
um
I need to just say this like we you've
heard stories where men have gloated
about oh absolutely 250 women you will
never hear a woman say that unless she's
from only fans you know I mean yeah
no I'm sorry I've just never experienced
that conversation because we're not
gonna brag about that stuff no and one
person but it goes back to a small
percentage of men are having a lot of
sex that's what he was saying earlier so
a small percentage of men they're the
biggest horror you know they're man
[__] right right and so you're right
there are a small percentage of men that
are having more sex than women but by
and large women are having more sex than
men I don't know I don't think that's
scary I'm scared
nobody's the contraceptive pills I'm
telling you it's all different products
you know why because what she's saying I
think is that the chances of a woman to
get more men and hide in it is measured
in a man getting a woman and you never
say something please go on sorry sorry
I'll say after I'll say after no because
think about every woman here yeah think
about think about your DMs yeah think
about now think about your DMs yeah yeah
now think about
if you really wanted to you could have
at least or good looking women anyway
not saying no I'm not you know what I
mean you could you could have anything
actually I'd like to kind of correct
just one thing one thing I'm gonna
correctly you can finish
um an average woman gets more matches on
dating apps than a top one person yeah
this is what I'm just about to say if
you look at your DMs you know for a fact
if you run if you just rang someone or
just said yeah come true how many
geezers could you have as many as you
wanted exactly that's what I'm saying so
realistically women probably do have the
more sex or we could do if we wanted to
yeah but what she's trying to say is
that you don't actually know how many
women they say it out loud
I'm just agreeing with what she said
because it's the truth because
realistically it's done it's the women
it is literally when you think about
your DMs because it's this crazy place
if you walked into a bar and you just
you stood in the bar and you said I will
[__] every Geezer here
imagine how many would do I mean imagine
how many how many members do they've
done that on YouTube before so yeah so
they have like a girl go up to guys and
a guy go up to girls and it's like over
half the guys are like okay because
she's a cute girl and they had a hot guy
go up to girls and it was like 99 of
them said no yeah exactly
that's what that was what went
so doesn't that show the statistics of
women trying to just keep themselves to
themselves like because okay all women
I'll be like oh they don't want extra
body count no I think I think it shows
what's easier to get like it's easier
for women to get sex than men yeah so
it's like men a man has to have
something for you to be interested in
home like you're a pretty girl so it's
like you're going to want them to have a
good job right definitely you want them
to be taller than you I've been I've
been very spoiled right yeah
you wanna you wanna so you are picky
earlier yeah okay
you want him to be taller than
do you find attractive usually would you
say I like men that are taller than me I
like to look up how tall are you so out
of out of ten men you maybe maybe you'll
find so if you're like the stats you'll
find too attractive so out of the 15
you're gonna find two out of the ten
that are over six foot attractive yeah
and let's say let's say one of them is
in your income category that you look
for and what is it so you're looking for
one percent of men and most women most
women are looking most women two baby
mums most women are looking for one
percent and you want them to have no
kids right that's right I want to be the
first and
that's what I'm saying it's all a
possibility like I said I did use some
date a very rich guy and he made me
become very high
um when we stopped dating I was like oh
my God how am I gonna get to right get
this level how am I no that's the thing
respect
statistically statistically you probably
won't replace him statistically you
probably want girls because it was real
I'm just saying my DM's be popular yeah
yeah but yeah yeah yeah
your DMs might be popping but
engagements count but that's what engage
okay okay I I I've had like crazy
messages but you you know come on DM
they don't count no no no it doesn't
count but obviously Lee out of those DMS
one of them did I mean I mean yeah
that's my point that's what every girl
thinks every girl's walking through life
thinking they're going to win the
lottery and date this top one percent
men he has to be over six foot he has to
make over 70k he has to be attractive he
has to be a champion but see this this
is this is but this is you're here wait
this is the problem that sounds nice
it's it sounds nice and like and it's
possible but it's not probable it's
probably not going to happen so so I'll
tell you I'll tell you another stat okay
so big banks are investing in things
like cat food wine because 50 of women
are projected to be single and childless
over 30. so that means all the girls in
this room half of us will never have
kids okay okay half of us will never get
married so if you say oh just manifest
it believe it sounds nice and it's also
like if you don't get married by 35 your
odds of getting married and having a
long stable relationship ever it's very
it's very low it's very low I actually a
lot of women yeah
foreign
[Music]
uh when a single woman reaches the age
of 30 the statistical probability of her
sex successfully finding a long-term
relationship and having just one child
Falls below 50 it then declines rapidly
by a 3.5 to 5 each year this is based on
the average fertility rates in developed
countries of course but it's also based
on the average amount of time it would
take a single 30 year old woman to find
a good mate and progress the
relationship to the point of pregnancy
um a little messed up is what you
consider the average age of first child
is 29 for women it varies very slightly
by country and most women start taking
the idea of a family seriously in their
late 20s and 30s
um
and let's talk about ivf2 61
um the the failure rates of IVF is 61.1
percent in women under 34. so out of 100
women that go and get IVF 61 fail um and
women that are between the ages of 35 to
38 73.7
86.2 percent in women ages 39 to 42 and
94 in women over the ages of 43 have
that's the IVF failure rate wow isn't it
now that there's more female binge
drinkers than male for the first time
ever yeah that's true that's crazy yeah
that's crazy which part there's more
female yeah there's more you can grab
yeah it was like it was something that
came out earlier this year that there
are now more female bench drinkers than
males and it's the first time in history
this has happened wow that's crazy I
really can get you again
today green so um okay there's there's
smoking more so so men smoke more and
women drink more yeah but that's the
first time
I'm going to read one more thing to you
guys according to the average span of
committed relationships a committed
dating relationships the average them
and the average interval of time women
take between relate relationships an
average woman has a maximum of guess how
many serious relationships three how
many four three plus two five five yeah
um
guys wait let me finish a maximum of
five serious relationships five swings
at a bat before her chance of starting a
family drops to zero so that means if
you've had five boyfriends your chance
of a family's dropped to zero wait wait
wait please can you explain that again
according to the average span of
committed dating relationships average
and the average interval of time women
take between relationships the average
woman has a maximum of five serious
relationships five swings at the bat
before her chances of starting a family
drops to zero
wait what if they what if the new
generation what if these people are just
willing to love easily more easily but
this is but this is like we always do a
roundabout way to make the numbers not
sound like what they are but this is
what any numbers when people started
creating numbers okay numbers wait
numbers were only numbers when people
started creating numbers
how did you counter Rock like how did I
found how many rocks before they were
okay this isn't this doesn't make any
sense
um
they do they do serve they do surveys
it's self-reported in different
countries around the world and they all
have similar numbers so so they they
start to have a similar conclusion and a
similar Trend so when we when we tell
women oh it's gonna be okay it's like my
DMs are full this this for a lot of
women for a lot of women it's not going
to be okay and out of women that don't
have kids eighty percent of them wish
they had them 100 that's gonna be okay
at the end of the day that's what I'm
saying sometimes these conversations
could also go to the other side of this
one room
so what do you think I think that these
sort of conversations we have they can
sometimes be very strategic and stats
have stated and these people yeah but
there's a whole group community of
people who don't do surveys and just
love their life and love people and talk
to people they're not real and they
don't give their reports back yes okay
okay
some some people you're right some
people don't take surveys but if we're
doing surveys in different places and
they're all concluding the same thing
it's like if you don't want to believe
numbers you don't have to you can just
live in the in the land of feelings but
but
you're right
it's by hard to do that when you're
living in the land of logic
okay should we do an episode that's just
like statistics and just teaching people
statistics we can say you're what you're
talking about is self-selection bias but
once you get over about 1400 people you
kind of have a pretty standard
distribution which is statistically
significant these numbers are pretty
damn tight so we'll do one episode Pro
for white school statistics what do you
think yeah I would love I would love to
each other so be honest with you to be
honest with you Demetrius yeah I feel
like Dimitri sorry
basically what I'm saying is that yes
you know not all of us were taught to be
wives yeah true and maybe that's because
our mothers saw what happened to wives
well I've not all of us would talk to
sucker Whoa stop wait wait wait no no no
no okay okay
um did you hear what I said first yeah
so so you say that again yes so just
just the one part just the part about we
they were not taught why yeah let me not
get him okay okay you're right what I'm
saying is that don't worry girl woman
that raised certain woman in this world
they never taught their children or
their daughters obviously wives because
they had experienced what happens to
wives and they were like I'm not gonna
be a wife because that means I have to
stand up with a guy and that's due to
right relationships but what what
outcomes are better
single childless women are not happy by
and large they're not over over there
over the age of our only happiness
though I mean what okay what do you want
your life to look like okay no no listen
listen two seconds just listen what do
you want your life to look like at 60
65. what do you want Christmas to look
like your fan your family's I just
wanted to look whole okay okay not
listen listen Okay what do you do you
want to spend it alone at 65. your
parents are probably passed away then on
70 65. for myself definitely not okay
for me personally right so what are you
arguing about here
I'm arguing that community and having
family and being a single woman doesn't
come with a lonely life
the stats disagree women the women that
don't have children are on
antidepressants
disagree that's okay that's okay because
so then what do you think you are
probably on
antidepressants and they on they drink
tap water and they do certain things
it's not fun no no and then you know
they're they're just okay are the are
those are the single childless women
that you know typically happy are they
happy they're in that position typically
like majority of the time okay they're
they're all happy yes and if they and if
they had to pick they would rather be by
themselves than with a man they respect
love and admire yeah they would prefer
that no no pick one what would they
prefer typically pick how could I pick
one if that's not an option if what's
I'm giving you two options they'd rather
be alone or with a man that they love
respect and admire which one would they
pick the rough wait
according to the stats you're right and
I'm wrong but according to my world and
my people my community
we're good but yeah we're good on this
but it's true what you said not a lot of
women have taught their um girls because
they haven't come from that background
no but no no no no no
through it because but why is that your
answer it's a painful reality
because we're not talking when I'm
saying the woman that we're not raised
to be wives it's because their mothers
had experienced something else
and that might be the majority that's
why there's so many women who aren't
wives who have to go to wives School she
means that it's a knock-on effect so say
someone's great grandma went through
some sort of trauma yeah as you
mentioned him earlier they're gonna pass
it down to their door yeah they ain't
gonna teach them how to then it goes
down so it's a knock-on effect what
they're saying it's generational
but the difference is people used to go
through trauma together yeah like I mean
I know a couple I know a couple that had
they lost a child and that that's real
trauma they lost a child and they they
stuck it out and they figured out a way
to make it work and they ended up having
more kids but that ruins most
relationships that's real trauma
nowadays women's trauma is just not
being happy having to listen to their
husband do you feel like this bro do you
feel like in this generation now a lot
of women are so quick to throw in the
towel is that what you feel like yes
yeah yeah and I agree with you I agree
all right
so I'm doing I'm doing a documentary on
the court system in the UK and I I can
tell you firsthand men are not the first
to throw in the technology
multiple times
so it might be for the kids but that the
men are more selfless than the women
because they care about the kids they'll
stick it out for the kids
I just interviewed a guy
I am talking about marriage she was
married he he has three daughters and he
was married to a narcissist and he said
that he would have stuck it out
but she wouldn't wow so then one day he
gets a call he can't go home she got a
restraining order against him she
accused him of abuse and now he can't
see his children three daughters and he
hasn't even gotten to fight in court in
the last year
and all he wants is just to see his kids
to bring his family together we hear
this and this woman had had no real
reason and I'm telling you I'm doing a
documentary on this it's like the same
story over and over again because here
the courts think about if you're if
you're in a contract right and person a
gets everything by leaving to get the
house they get the kids they get
everything in person B
um they lose everything person B is
always trying to to please person a
because they have more to lose so Matt
it changes the way we interact in
relationships in my opinion where that's
why we always have like women wearing
the pants especially in the west because
the men are always trying to appease the
women because they lose everything if
they leave so yeah I do I do think women
today throw on the towel and partially
it's because they're paid to hey Pearl
I've had clients cry to me I've had like
in law offices the partners I've had
them cry to me over the years because of
the divorce they're going through and
not being able to see their kids and
it's and it's like and we know
statistically it's 80 of women that
leave their relationships I've had grown
ass men cry to me about it like I've had
that relation where they're like dude
and they just ball yeah I know many men
I know men I've met many men who are
actually depressed and that's how they
go into depression because they've lost
their kids and the mother is usually
being spotful or just not letting them
see their kid not giving them the right
can I say something though
um I don't want to justify the thing
that
um women sometimes they can be evil and
take their kids and use them against
their husbands but you have to check how
many marriage are made where the woman
she does everything she goes to work she
take care of kids she does everything
and the man just goes to work and goes
home and chills sit down like you don't
really know the reason why people
divorce and like I believe there's so
many marriages nowadays why did she have
a kid with a guy that just sits at the
couch all day I mean why did she pick
him not because the most of the men they
say that like men in business or
whatever
Men by and large make more than women
sorry Men by and large make more than
women yeah I know but because they make
more than women they they feel that they
are able to like just go home and chill
or watch the TV or go with their friends
to drink a beer while the woman actually
goes to work she looks after the kids
she take care of the house she pays the
bill she does she does everything
okay this is literally we talked about
this today with Creole so this is really
interesting and again this is going to
be super offensive so let's go viral
first thing okay
like
Messi the football soccer football
player his wife isn't leaving him
because he doesn't do the dishes one of
the whites like I left him because he
didn't do the chores it's like that
LeBron is LeBron's wife leaving him
because he doesn't do the dishes that's
a [__] reason that's not true let me
tell you what is true the answer is he's
not if if a wife is like I'm leaving
because my husband doesn't do chores
it's because he's not making enough
money that's the reason now and and the
stats I'll make it very simple and you
guys are gonna hate this I told it's
going to be here it's true so so I that
makes sense listen up I come I come home
if you do the logic I come home and I'm
like I just work like a 14-hour day I'm
super tired you know I whatever pull my
portion next to my wife's G wagon that I
got her she's very cool everything's
great and I'm freaking tired and I can
see my wife we should we have four kids
she's working really hard around the
house and I'm like honey listen
um let me just get a maid to come in and
clean the house
and my wife's like no no I I want to do
this myself and I'm like look I know I'm
not gonna do it I'll tell you I'm not
gonna I just worked 14 hours I'm gonna
touch a dish in my life and I told her
if I'm single I have a full-time living
maid and my like I'll literally get a
nanny for myself if I'm single and she
will just do everything so finally I
convinced my wife
to get a lady to come in and help around
the house so in comes like this hot 23
year old Ukrainian girl that's now
living in Estonia as a refugee and she's
in there wiping the everything I see my
wife do the side she never showed up
again
what I'm saying is gentlemen this is
going to be offensive listen up if you
ever if you were don't want to do dishes
and you are successful enough to hire a
mate hire a hot maid and I promise your
wife will do the damn dishes
I want to give you guys a stat wait no
wait um surprisingly studies showed that
the divorce rate among couples who share
um chores equally was 50 higher than
among those where the wife does the
majority of the work it's a financial
yeah I know but I'm not saying I'm not
saying because the men like because the
men doesn't do because obviously the
woman for nature like even like in all
the religion right the woman is the one
that she looks after the kids after the
house and everything but like at the
same time if a man can make like that
type of amount of money that he can come
home until then why her wife's shoe
should go to work and be like oh I have
to take care of everything like if she
if her wife can decide to be at home and
be like oh don't want to have like a
really do you think a successful men
want their wives to work does your wife
work no I told her when I married her I
said I want my mom worked my mom outer
and my dad so my parents got divorced
and it was and I saw it as a kid I
wasn't a dumb kid I'm like I know why
it's happening because my mom started
out earning my dad I told my wife I'm
like look when we get married I want my
wife to be a stay-at-home mom I was very
open about it it's because I want my
kids have an experience I didn't have
and I want to work my ass off to provide
my kids that experience okay can I just
put that in there the last guy I was hit
with even though he wanted me to have
this and I have that he wanted me to do
all of that he did not want me to stay
at home and raise kids he wanted me to
go to work and I thought well listen if
you're the breadwinner and you're the
alpha why would you want to put so much
pressure
one thing guys so this is a topic that's
come up here and I I I I'm so you're
like look let's imagine we group men
into two groups okay some men are slimy
and and they just have you know bad
character and they and they mistreat you
and maybe you know some of us were
unfortunate enough to grow up with with
a father like that I just want to give a
shout out to my dad by the way who never
made a lot of money in his life he's
still a mechanic to this day he's in his
60s he's never gonna retire but man did
he give me a good example of a man who
suffers in dignity my God he just he
suffers in dignity and I know he [__]
hates it pardon my French but he
suffered indignity for me because you
know he had a son meet so we can group
the man into these two categories the
Slime balls and then we have guys that
like genuinely want an optimal outcome
for their family Pearl I think your dad
sounds like he might be that kind of guy
are there any other by the way folks
here with a guy with a dad like that oh
my goodness so about 50 you can see 50
okay so and this is a painful question
to ask but I would ask this question
because if I'm coaching a young man or
woman in our company
and they are continuously getting a
negative outcome I would ask well if 50
of the guys are the good guys why aren't
they picking you like why are you being
picked by these guys that are
problematic guys because that's the
experience you're describing what about
the good guys exist and they're picking
somebody we exist maybe picking you
maybe them slyballs know who to pre-on
and they just see it so why are you such
a juicy Target for that and why why why
are you going for it well guys
wait wait this is my issue it's like
okay once I'll give you one all right
but it's like girls will pick two three
four like at some point it's a pattern
it's you men can be very deceiving in
the beginning they can be lovely they
can be kind but
no but that's the men you pick that's
half them until you get to know them
give it three months six months down the
line then we start giving them
conversation shall we have the kids
shall we move in do you want to do that
yeah of course so we're speaking about
live we're not trying to waste time
either in or out are you the judge of
character
I think so well that doesn't sound like
it no is because at the end of the day
if you come across a good man he's
hard-working he's very dedicated to his
own game he's alpha male and you know
you're going to give him that time a day
because you think oh I like this energy
I like this song He's giving me me I
have so many to pick from and I haven't
chose yet yeah okay I have many that I
can actually say I can settle down baby
cap it's like no no I can show you my
taxes I'm talking about text I'm just
saying many groups
it's any girl if you're if you're single
that you're okay for that if you're
single it's like then you're not the
guys you want don't want a journey I
think it could be a multi-millionaire so
no if you're if you're single come on if
a guy if a guy really you thought was
taking you serious and checked all your
boxes you'd go for it anyway yeah but
I'm a picky person that's
goes back to my point though because the
men the men that are going for you don't
live up to your standards either your
standards are too high actually that
aren't going there is one particular
person and I'm like wow you really did
do that like he read and I'm really
shocked and I'm really proud of the man
he's become and I'm known him for many
years and you know we could have been in
a relationship say 15 years ago but I
was like no I've come to London and I'm
on a journey and I don't want to be
distracted by these guys because guess
what they're gonna breathe put give a
baby to you
no not necessarily of course you do I'm
on a journey how can I be judging
characters
do you have kids no I don't have kids
and you said you're 39 yes do you want
kids
um with the right person if I don't I
have many nieces and nephews okay so how
about a big family but but it goes back
to you haven't found the right person to
have kids with so so again again I've
been picking again right so so there's
there's a Miss there's a miss
very high you don't know how to pick and
maybe you don't have a good judge of
character or the men that you want don't
want you it's one of the three like
there has to be disconnected I wanted
they probably don't want me no more
because we're in a different category
he's in he's far away I would have to
move to his location and then the ones
in England I don't know
you've been dating you've been dating
since what you're 18 16. so in 20 years
you're the only common denominator it
can't be harder than men
it's not me though it's because if I
have some guys that are you know it may
be waiting for me to say yes you know
what I mean that's just mine
okay it might be your life choices it
might be but but it goes back to you're
the common denominator they're just like
my outcomes it's it's my fault
everyone's own outcomes are their own
fault it's choices Stars hey can I give
us I really think it's the energy that
she's doing that because you're in your
you're in your place where you want to
go high up in life you're also not
giving those energy to those men that's
why things like that mean as well that's
what I'm listening you can't waste time
guys I'm uh I'm gonna do a little
business thing here you want you said
you want to be a multi-million be super
successful right yeah I'm gonna give you
I'm about to make you a multi-freaking
Miller you ready for this start a cat
food company and call your friends you
will make millions no I don't have
friends like that no I'm sorry you might
you might make sure
when are you gonna be a millionaire bye
well there's no time plan but we're
working on the job okay so we're doing
everything possible to make it do you
have over half a million saved no I've
got some money saved uh okay so but it's
like when you've had 20 years to do it I
mean it's not about when you know what
it is about when and it's
because if I have such a high mentality
I need somebody to match that much okay
and they can't bring me down so at the
at the rate I'm at I'm 26. okay I'm 26.
I probably will be a millionaire in the
next five years no no it's not even like
that but I'm saying but I'm saying but I
could tell you I didn't need anyone else
to help me do it good I just did it and
it's and it's like
if you're 39 and you're not on the
actual path to being a millionaire like
wow
until it was 26. but but my my whole
point but so it's still been 15 years
that I had to come
from a different city no let me give you
the statistics from a different city
okay I had to start fresh again okay who
came here with nothing with nobody yeah
I did that a year ago you did it a year
ago maybe you had a bit more supportive
parents I don't have supportive parents
my dad has passed away and my mom she's
a single mom so no I can't look to my
family for anything so everything is all
by myself which is which is fine you
know I mean you can phone your dad and
say Dad what a story I've got a I've got
a problem
yeah you still have that same problem
and that's what I'm saying I am changing
every day and every day okay I'm getting
better and better and that's what I do
know for me it's not about pleasing
this is
if you're going to be a millionaire and
this is like this just sounds that is a
Dream It's a dream it's just it's the
dream yeah because we're working towards
it how I do properties you didn't ask me
my life story I do properties I do
acting I do music I'm all on
intellectual property intellectual
property takes time then your property
games take time as well you know what I
mean I've been working on properties
since 2017. I didn't leave school with
any jcses and I've just finished
University four weeks ago so I had to go
through that journey of becoming
intellectual for me to go on these I
think you're still going to have the
type of energy you had in your 20s in
your 40s and 50s maybe not but guess
what we're gonna keep on going but
you're gonna be competing with the
people in their 20s and their 30s
there's no competition
can I just say one thing please babe you
know you're saying you're not in
competition my daughter is going to be
18 in July so you really think that
you're going to have the same sort of
the same energy that's what you're just
saying the same energy and the same
drive and the same opportunities that my
18 year old daughter because you're
you're going to be in the same gene but
would your daughter be doing the same
things that I'm doing who knows probably
not if she wants to be successful like
but she could be you know what I mean
she could be but we're going to be in a
whole different category I'm going to be
in the say the 40 to 45. she's going to
be 18 to 25. this is this is a lot of
things
this is my point though for you it's
like you're 39. it doesn't sound like it
doesn't it doesn't no no I'm I'm I'm
just being honest it doesn't sound like
it doesn't sound like you're on track to
be a man
you're saying it doesn't sound like your
entry you might be leaving statistics
okay okay yeah I'll die
of course not but business business okay
okay I'll give you something business
people usually believe in statistics
you're gonna look at your Market you're
going to look at the people you're
selling you believe in statistics but if
you want to be a millionaire you
probably should believe in statistics
so now now you're at the point it's like
you you want a family with the right guy
and I can tell you do but it's like
you're curving the guy that you said
would be a good relationship for you for
15 years but attraction is everything no
it's not it is it's not it is when
you're younger but when you're older
it's like you you got to pick you're
poisoned I'll be single that I'm happy
do you have money that you could be
saved for retirement like what do we
need 1.5 million to retire they're all
working on it because I wasn't around
the people that was going for those
goals I had to take myself out of my
environment but this is you can't you
can't blame them the generational cause
environment my dad grew up my dad grew
up my dad grew up on the south side of
Chicago with 13 kids he didn't grow up
in a good environment none of his
siblings are successful full it's either
you're going to be successful or you're
not and most of the time people that are
going to be millionaires are on the way
by the time they're your age because it
you'd have to compete with the people
that are in their 20s and 30s and have
way more energy than you're going to
that does not matter because everybody's
going to be evolving differently can I
uh this is like the reason
um I think some of us are a little bit
taken back is like you're obviously
intelligent no I'm just I'm talking
about my life can I add something
I really feel like with the cost of
living a million pound is nothing goes
on that's the time
right okay sorry go ahead go ahead so
sorry I forgot your name Abby I've been
Abby Abby Abby apologize for that um
you're obviously intelligent like
there's no question we can tell like
your thoughts are there you're you look
nice you know like you're a nice looking
lady you're smart you're verbal
intelligence is fairly high like you
think fast you talk fast
there's there's a lot of opportunity a
lot of potential you recognize your own
potential you know that yeah so that's
why I'm not even involved by competition
the delusion like you don't have to sell
us anymore on that we already know but
you're smart you're you're well spoken
you're you're beautiful like you have a
lot of the potential is incredible the
potential is incredible
but but there's the I had this situation
this situation this situation this
situation now Pearl's Dad one of 13
certainly didn't grow up very privileged
right so you guys meet like real simple
like I grew up as a Jew in the Soviet
Union which was not a happy place for
Jews uh we immigrated to Canada in 92
which we're eating at the food bank and
then
here here's what happened to me I'll
tell you guys a quick story and I hope
it's interesting right
um I was rollerblading like a complete
loser rollerblading uh like four or five
kilometers to go from my parked car on
the highway to my university because I
couldn't afford the 75 cents a day they
were charging for parking at my
University because I was paying my own
School
so I was rollerblading I would park on
the highway and I would rollerblade like
a good hour to get to my University
campus and somebody saw me do that and
they go wow you're so motivated you know
I can see you like you want to stay in
shape blah blah blah and I'm too
embarrassed to tell this person I'm just
freaking poor like I can't afford the 75
cents you know you're motivated but but
here but here's the thing
I was lucky because I met a mentor
somebody that said hey you know you want
to do better than this I was like yeah
and that's a dangerous thing I was like
19 or 20. it's a dangerous thing and
this person said to me hey I work on
this company and all this person was
doing a selling encyclopedias
door-to-door and they said you can go do
this and that's that's what I did for
six years how I paid for University it's
and I got like two degrees by selling
encyclopedias door to door for six years
luckily fortunately for me I met a
mentor that saw my potential saw my
energy and I was delusional because
whatever I was doing I couldn't afford
75 cents for parking so I knew that I
was delusional because what I wanted was
not what I had in my life fair enough
I'm going to give a plug so that's what
we do on our company 53 of our sales
people make six figures within 18 months
53 the reason I plug us here is lgbt.com
really simple
what you need is like to be around
somebody that's actually done what you
want to do and not make up stories of
how it works like there are people that
have done what you want to do find those
people and they'll be so happy happy to
Mentor you because that's what we do in
our company why don't you think I'm not
in those group of people what makes you
think I am not even around the answer is
results but my journey actually started
properly at 26 years old 13 years ago to
London I still had to educate myself I
came here with 108 pounds in my pocket
tell me how I'm gonna sort myself out
get my house created
I'm gonna let him go I don't think he's
talked yet
to your point uh you was talking about
how you came here with a hundred pounds
yeah I immigrated from Bulgaria with my
parents and we lived in a single room it
was just a single room the three of us
and right now I'm 21 and just like you I
wanted to do better for myself off
because I was an electrician and I
wasn't happy with how things were going
and I joined and all of a sudden I'm
meeting High net worth individuals on a
daily basis and I'm improving myself and
you're here saying I had to take myself
from the toxic situations that I had in
my life but everyone deals with them so
that's really an excuse that you tell
yourself that's true but can I say
something
um
for you can look like an excuse yeah but
we're trying to see you you had steal
your parents on your back you came with
your parents on a single room but you
were with your parents you were not by
yourself you were not providing food by
yourself you were not paying your bills
by yourself you were not looking around
I was yeah okay
I understand it I understand her because
I get it she I don't know your past but
before moving to London maybe you didn't
maybe you were just I don't know you're
going through love the difficulties of
learning consultant well I don't know
you came London and the thing is I get
it because some people they don't see as
let's discover some people want to
better themselves and educate themselves
and so that they know how to
intellectually grow
the people that are successful don't
educate themselves they just do exactly
they don't they don't spend time
I don't have education no I'm saying you
had the right people around you
you know what I'm trying to say no
everyone's gone but you choose but okay
at 18 that's an excuse but at 40 you
picture you surround yourself I'll give
you an example one time I decided I
wanted more rich friends I literally was
just like my friends are too broke I'm
around a bunch of brokies
and so you know I lived I lived in
Milwaukee at the time and I worked I
worked a sales job so I was like you
know what I want to just see if I can
call some of these numbers and see if
any of these Executives because I
definitely I was trying to sell copy or
send them one to meet with me but I was
like I'm gonna see if they'll get coffee
with me and just like um and see if they
can mentor me ask them about their
success I got three c-level Executives
of multi-million dollar companies to
literally sit down spend 30 minutes of
me just by asking and yes
another time another time this is for a
YouTube video right I was just bored one
day and you know people will always you
know say it's because I'm a girl or
because of this or because of that
whatever but like honestly I I feel like
I could do this with anyone I I um I did
this for a YouTube video I didn't have a
job because I quit my job to be a tick
tocker I know and yeah I quit I was
working in sales and I was doing quite
well but I just quit it to do to do Tick
Tock and I moved home with my parents
and I was like maybe I'll see if I could
find a job in a day so I went to this
rich neighborhood um and it's by Chicago
it's like where all the rich people are
and I was like I wonder if I go door to
door I like snuck into the Gated area I
know and um I was like I wonder if I go
door to door in this neighborhood and
just ask people for a job within one day
I got an interview for a sales job now I
didn't want the job so I didn't end up
taking it because I was just trying to
do YouTube but but the point is like
it's all about like you can you have two
choices in life everything can be an
excuse
I came here 13 years ago I was learning
I only had a hundred dollars in my
pocket
but it is because honestly the people
and I'm telling you I'm around these
people the people that are really
successful they don't talk about that
they just talk about what they're doing
they're so excited about this next
project it's this this and this yeah
and maybe and maybe you are but I'm
saying the way you've represented
yourself in this conversation is it's
always an excuse It's like it's
a very cautious but it's it's it's it's
describing what it is it's describing
it's wait wait it's describing outcomes
and it's like you've had 13 years
outcomes I had to deal with
everyone's got stuff to deal with what
did you have to deal with it it's not
nobody I I came to this country by
myself well alone I didn't know anyone
in this country so I mean have other
people had it harder did you have it
harder sure but I'm telling you I know
people in worse situations that made
more so I don't know I feel like you're
talking from a privileged place yes
this is the thing and I'll tell you I'm
a generation I'm talking about no no no
no I'm talking from a privileged place
and being around these types of people
so I can tell you the people that have
had good outcomes and I know people that
have had good outcomes for wait I know
people that have had good outcomes from
the bottom I've known people that have
had good outcomes from the top and I can
tell you the way they talk isn't the way
you talk because because they're not
always talking about the reasons they
didn't succeed they're talking about
to answer questions though you know I
mean you've got to I'm answering the
questions that you're putting out there
you know have you got a boyfriend no how
about you 39. so I'm responding you know
if you ask me now okay what do you do
now nobody's asked me that you only be
like oh you're making making excuses I'm
not I'm revolving the information you
gave you offered it was it didn't really
have much to do with every question I
had a question I believe did you want to
raise your you go to your handwriters
yeah I just wanted to add to her point
about uh you don't haven't uh don't have
any bills to pay when you're 18 living
with your parents but uh everyone has
their situations and in fact uh during
the coronavirus I was maybe like 19 I
had to basically uh pay for the whole
family my mom and dad went out of
business and I was the only man in the
house that was earning money and
providing for the house so there is
different things that people go through
and again you can't judge on them and
I'm not trying to judge you and to your
point that you had a hundred pounds in
your account when you came here to be
fair you don't really need money to make
money as long as you're willing I feel
like they're in this conversation we're
trying to put the finger on each person
and be like oh are you this you do each
person is different each person yes so
each person different like I see what I
would say although we're all having
conversations and we're sharing
experience and stuff about our own lives
we feel like we're being vulnerable
because we're showing information
actually I don't see that anybody here
it might feel like people are being
personally attacked but it's not and I'm
hearing like I can hear that you're
feeling a bit maybe getting a bit
defensive because I don't think yeah I
agree words are powerful but it's also
words that are down to interpretation so
somebody could say to me that I'm making
an excuse I'm not going to be defensive
at somebody saying I'm making an excuse
that might make me think to myself okay
could I have done something more could I
have done this okay it's all how we how
we take it and how we understand and it
so everyone's circumstances are their
own there's no competition as you said
maybe you felt like Pearl was talking
from a place of privilege somebody else
might think that you're talking from a
place of privilege you know everyone's
circumstances and situations are their
own all you have to do is know that
you're doing the best that you can do
but it's also very important that you
need to be realistic I think that I
think as soon as we start being honest
with ourselves and truthful with
ourselves about where we lack where we
could do more where we need to be more
disciplined or the changes that we need
to make then you will really see like a
a propeller of energy and you will go
into the area that you want to go in but
I think that people spend a lot of time
procrastinating and hesitating and I'm
not saying that you are doing that but
people do spend a lot of time
procrastinating hesitating they're not
in the right circles they're not having
the right influences but they still
believe that they're going to achieve
the things that they want to achieve
that's okay you can still believe that
but I don't think that you I don't think
that the word excuse was supposed to be
an attack on you I think excuses what a
lot of people do yeah
what people do but you gotta you gotta
you gotta look at the Timeline you know
but that's just for your person
I could have probably done this a bit
more I could have done this I could have
went College earlier but at the end of
the day you don't know the challenges
one has to face to make me end up in
sickness to you guys
you know Pearl right you know no pearl
you've met no I've met her today you
have a wonderful you have a wonderful
example of somebody that came to a new
country that has created a significance
I've met you today because now I'm
evolving around these significant
following significant future yeah but
it's like I give you I tell you
something and you argue it and you argue
because you have to Stand My Ground up
because I know my heart and if you're
saying oh you make the excuses
I've had successful people tell me that
before and my reaction is oh [__] you're
probably right because they know
something you don't
or anything but I'm a very strong woman
and I Will Stand My Ground and I would
like to be heard and I'm going to be
heard regardless I want you to
understand not even understand I want
you to overstand like the way you did
you know you know the type of background
I'm coming from if I tell you some
horror stories that I've done yeah it
will it will I had to change my
mentality I had to deal
I get the process and I get how and it's
different for different people it's
upbringing and how we've also been
taught how to deal with certain
situations in life if we're not taught
initially just by not sorting out
certain situations we go back so that's
where people get some Advantage
somewhere people get disadvantaged and
it is what it is Journeys are journeys
imagine you changing your mentality and
you're going back to your friends that
you used to speak to in 16 18 20 and
you're telling them the journey who
don't even understand anything to
yourself you know what I need new
friends I need I ain't gonna lie
so I just speak to them do you not girl
just and they understand just being plus
size right I'm not even gonna allow in
different weight changes I was being
treated differently so that just goes to
show like when I saw pre-pandemic I
became 28 songs I got ill so I was 28
stones and I'm not gonna allow people
are really being mean to me and I'm a
person who I'm not quite a happy
cheering person I love speaking to other
people on the tube and just talking to
people and making conversation but when
I lost that way I'm telling you after
pandemic I lost eight stones and people
treated me differently and I'm never
gonna lie even business way a lot of
people come up to and be like oh my God
you've got something and we'd like to
work with you so we just goes to show
how sometimes by looks and how you are
people also you have to be the change
that people will believe
you got to be the change see I just
sometimes you see you guys are saying
things and I feel like they mean nothing
no so that's because if you feel the
hardship and the and if you feel that if
you've been to through the hardship and
you've gone through the cycle of
actually okay getting Gap from this
hardship then you'd you'd understand the
feeling if you don't understand the
feeling if you haven't gone through the
process it's really hard to understand
say it's not about the feeling like if
we're talking about success right we're
talking about business success it's what
what are you doing so I'll give you an
example when I first started this all
right it was just me I was in a living
room in a small apartment in East London
and I was running to the gym trying to
get people to get the gym to come on my
podcast and then I could say this is
what I'm doing but it's like when we
talk about oh this is a feeling we're
evolving mentally it's like it's like
what is it
that's what I'm saying you've come from
a privileged place where your mindset
has been amazing for you I had to change
my mindset babe you're 39 this is this
is like a conversation with the 60s and
I started changing my mindset say about
27 28 when I realized that I had to
deeper okay so yeah as a teenager
like
so but but what are the results like
that's my thing the results is you you
still can't have a conversation without
without getting defensive and it's like
you need to be right I'm telling when
you're being attacked from people that
don't know your life stories
then no but give me the right word
across a little bit defensive and the
topic was yeah the subject was about
profession like in business being
successful in business yeah so so but
but what you but the conversation has
gone into like a spiritual journey
that's not business that's totally
separate logically yeah
basically I I get what you're seeing
everything's about feelings emotions but
that's not what business is about but
sometimes people actually don't know
business and they need to learn their
lessons and then they get business and
then they flourish and I think that's
where she's coming from and I get your
point as well because I get it when you
say but you're talking about feelings
and things but feelings get involved
when you learn a lesson and then you
need to try again get back up fail try
again so is that what happened to you I
don't know you don't need to answer
actually don't have to reprogram so
probably yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna Read
Super chats really quick
um okay
um guys thank you for the super chats
blessing what are we saving for right
now we're doing a third Studio what are
you wanting it what's your dream wish
list
you have any more cameras I've given you
so many cameras how many more do you
want Oh My Gosh
fine guys we're gonna get blessing
another camera do you guys see how many
cameras we have that was so many things
really he's a camera that's what I said
he's a camera addict
he's lucky he's talented um okay Chris
Abby prioritizes winning an argument
over learning from others stand your
ground and be wrong you are being heard
but you were still broke and alone
Amelia I have her back in a year to see
if she made it Zoros lost notice how
masculine uh men in suits and feminine
women left to the couch listens to
understand but masculine women and
feminine feminine men listen to respond
with emotion um zorroslop
thank you 39 years old you're a prime
example um that I've made a great a
decision to invest in Nimble food wine
and IVF fellas let's make our monies
Johnny Dimitri is King I need to afford
a maid
um you're something um some women only
believe in spousal abuse statistics uh
Matt butcher ladies if you're in a good
Man's Shoes men lose half their [__] in
kids women very very rarely go through
that I've seen men go through that
repeatedly men get after extremely
disappointing 90 Frito pie women cannot
be honest because they always have
someone in mind they don't want to hurt
you can't be honest about relationships
until you've realized the truth about
your own parents have you done that fast
car women don't like numbers and they
don't paint a pretty picture for them
say this women are beautiful you know
what you you know what you're worth not
really reality is Harsh only women and
children are allowed to live in delusion
I'm 90 free topai Pearl uh
um scream for peace successful wives of
wealthy men are like good dance partners
and know how to lead and when to back
lead interracial relationships uh coming
from a sex positive lifestyle trauma a
life-changing experience when changes
your entire core belief and or
personality do women understand the
importance of sex
men require for commitment Matt butcher
can you wife at 304 unstable people seek
out enablers to validate their behavior
that's a downward spiral identify it
don't get sucked into it great job
reading super chats today Pearl um
Dion Dimitri is the Godfather of the
show The Others need to pay attention to
him and listen to him he knows his stuff
Doug MPA the panel doesn't deserve to
share the room with Dimitri he has so
much knowledge and you are squashing
this opportunity listen and learn
um YT silk is a woman over a woman who
overlooks red flags trustworthy Matt
butcher uh 50s to 60s ladies I want
someone to grow old with equals I want
someone to fund my retirement okay so
back to the waifa health yeah me too and
someone please fund my retirement as
well
so yeah nothing nothing by the way gives
me more pleasure than like to provide
for my wife that like it's so
um fun because man I went to the airport
this morning and I'm stupid I forgot my
passport I called my wife she's like did
you forget password like yes they did
she's like I'll be right there she
literally dropped everything like got
whichever kid was at home in the car and
drove straight to the airport and I and
I as I said it's her 10-year wedding
anniversary and I said I'm so glad you
know if I wasn't married to for these
last 10 years I would be missing a fight
right now
but you know but there are so many
there's so many little things that
she'll do to like actually make my life
easier because she's because she's
actually figured beautiful but it wasn't
but it wasn't because like it just she
figured out that like because she loves
you as well well well of course I hope I
mean I would I would hope she loves you
and she knows that you love her but but
you know it's like I would love to find
somebody to fund my retirement well
actually let's just say that's true of
course you would of course he would who
wouldn't want that right but it's like
are you the person like are you a person
that guy picks and that's that's a
question we talk about this in business
it's like you see a prospect he doesn't
buy it's like our like that Prospect is
going to buy that product somewhere at
some point but are you are you being the
person that that Prospect wants to buy
from
you know and so it shifts the
responsibility on me to better my and so
I'll tell you guys that's sorry I was 20
I was 22 I was 22 years old I was
sitting down with a mentor of mine who
had like a massive impact on my life he
was about 40 years old like extremely
successful with women with finances
everything the guy was just the stud
went on to become a VP of a public
company that sold for like a billion
dollars just crazy private companies so
[__] those are crazy
and I asked them and I was really really
frustrated I was 22 years old I hadn't
got laid in about a year
[Music]
I was 22 and been late in about a year
wow that was a bad choice
um because because look look I didn't
kiss the girls until I was 20 that's why
because I I needed to I didn't
understand the reality of what I was
dealing with I had delusions in my mind
like I thought I would meet a girl 20
and marry her because my grandparents
were both married until everybody died
all both sets of grandparents to meet
you oh she's something yeah like
what's your thoughts obviously you're a
married man and I've always wanted to
ask some mandis
obviously of your level and it's like
what do you think about
um what's it called again prenup yeah
what do you think about that dude
against the marriages of this guy man I
have a really I have some really
controversial opinions on this and if
you'd like me to shout out share
um
I had two conditions uh three conditions
for for getting married
the first condition was my wife has to
take my last name
it wasn't a religious Choice it was that
a mentor of mine told me that it
signified something my mom didn't take
my dad's last name and they got divorced
and I saw that my mom didn't respect my
dad like I felt he deserved the respect
even though he suffered he suffered with
dignity that was number one
uh number two no prenup
that was a decision I made principally I
made that decision no prenup like I told
my wife like I didn't know if I was ever
gonna get married but if I went for it I
was gonna go all in but I'm gonna make a
real strategic decision I'm gonna go all
freaking in that's the way it should be
that that was the way that was love that
was my choice and I admit it might not
be the most because people are going to
say oh but you're a businessman you're
making a discount you know not a risk
mitigating decision I made a choice but
you know I'll tell you something my
wife's told me this many many times like
sort of in a playful way kind of talk
you know because we have hard
conversations sometimes she's like look
if you divorce me I don't want any money
I just she just said I just want to make
sure that I have the kids and I said
that's great that's what I want too
right
um but but that's but I made that
decision I made that decision to step
into that and say I'm gonna risk
everything because maybe it's a
courageous you know delusion that I had
at the time and maybe I'm just lucky
that it worked out the way it has so far
so would you say that there's no room or
right when it comes to that kind of
decision I was it down to you as an
individual because it is like a business
is kind of marriage marriage to marriage
to me was uh look look again 85 percent
are the laws different in the country
you're in are they I'm not compared in
Canada first oh okay so that's not
getting worse that is a terrible place
to do it right okay really
um why well because the Canadian court
system just is like Australia or the US
it just really favors women
but but you know what but I felt like I
vouched my wife's character you know
what's crazy my wife's never had a
public Instagram I'll just tell you
right now she never had it by the way
people that meet my wife they're like
wow Dimitri like really like they're
impressed that I got a girl of that
caliber because she's you know five ten
blonde don't nod your head are you
better no not cool you know my wife's
like like I have a type and it's her
like 5 10 blonde like you know people
say wow is she like a model or something
because you know so I did well in that
regard but I vouched her I like vetted
her character so like no public
Instagram I'm gonna say this no tattoos
no piercings okay hate me I don't care
no tattoos no peers things no public
Instagram great relationship with her
dad or Dad's a heart surgeon like
incredible like successful Stern man
great relations with one of three
sisters she's the oldest of three uh
educated uh could have a lot of dudes
chose not to uh and in fact I was my
wife and I have my wife's first and only
serious relationship
wow so I guess if you choose right
you don't need the degrees for life well
and of course like what bigger decision
can a man make than to get married like
everything right I I I I I kind of hear
what he's saying I think when you're
looking for a partner
you need to actually look at do they
actually Little Things
does it match with the person and if
they're little things match and if you
can deal with one another's differences
in opinions I think that's that's a
winner because then you're showing that
you have respect in your listening and
you're working as a team how a
relationship should be I have a question
sorry go ahead go ahead I was gonna fix
I'm sitting with my mentor I'm 22 years
old I remembered very vividly like I I
got to the party late you know what I
mean like I didn't kiss a girl until I
was 20.
um and then like I'm 22 and I'm single
and I'm frustrated and my life is not
going the way I wanted to go and I'm
like why am I like why by the way by 23
a lot of things I bought my first house
at 23 and I was a full-time University
student so like there was a lot of
changes that I was undergoing like I
started going to the gym I started doing
things that sucked like I took cold
showers every freaking morning in fact
my 1988 Toyota Corolla actual 1988
Toyota Corolla that I took a girl on a
date on told me that she'll never go on
a date with me again because my car
smells like old people and she thought I
was a psycho which makes sense because
my Corolla had a Ferrari sticker on the
steering wheel so Tony Robbins no is
Napoleon Hill secrets of whatever
Napoleon Hill playing and motivational
quotes posted on all the mirrors so I
look like a crazy person right okay so
anyways 22 I'm sitting with a mentor of
mine I'm like and I said dude like how
do I get a happy and successful
girlfriend I want a girlfriend you've
done the Mandarin for the girlfriend
well I just that's who I was at 22. yeah
I I went through the other phase too by
the way like like
I went through that and if you're
listening to Napoleon Hill at 22 wow but
obviously because well guys because
I lived in the actual projects well done
like I live like you know the projects
are social housing I introduced you to
him
um literally I was rollerblading and
somebody's like recruited me to go into
sales like hey you look really motivated
come to sales and I'm like oh they think
I'm motivated I'm just poor I'm just
poor but here's the and by the way like
so so he I said how do I get a happy and
successful girlfriend at the time I was
just I just wanted a girl to like me I
wasn't thinking about like anything else
yeah of course he goes he goes oh that's
easy you just have to be happy and
successful
and I thought about that a lot and it
comes back to the you know McConaughey
quote he does the thing like don't chase
the butterfly build a garden the
butterflies will come so a mentor of
mine
impact on my life like he really told me
like he's like just build your own value
focus on you and do everything you need
to do to be the most attractive guy to
the to women around you because I wasn't
an attractive guy to him around me I was
rollerblading to University in the 1988
Corolla was falling apart the driving
test I took the first time he didn't let
me drive the car I said I borrow my
dad's car because he said the car does
not look safe
so you know at 22 I'm not a good
Prospect for women so like now my mind
changed like oh it's not that I'm not
good at getting women is that women
don't want me why not well because I'm
22 and I was a at the time I was going
to University I was professionally
gaming I was playing games 14 15 hours a
day I stunk so Dimitri why do you think
you were able to take that feedback
where most women if you say the men you
want don't want you because the pain of
staying the same was greater than the
pain of change it just hurt too freaking
much to be fair at 22 men are at that
level where they're not
um they're not as highly you know I'm
talking from a perspective or 22 year
old man and a 22 year old woman yeah
yeah a 22 year old role a 22 year old
woman is a lot more desired than a 22
year old man at that stage but we could
use the opposite like a 42 year old man
and a 42 year old woman yeah the man's
gonna be a lot more desired than the
woman definitely because now he's in
these games it actually it switches for
women about 30 um according to dating
apps yeah yeah where it's all facts it's
like where the tables turn well and
there's and there's a wisdom there too
like why do I get married I'll say why I
have friends that are 40 that are very
successful they never got married right
um I kind of looked at it like I
understand obviously that men's value
grows with time and women value like
this whatever you call sexual market
value goes down yeah yeah
but but that's like what actually in my
opinion my this is an opinion in my
opinion it's what makes a successful man
a man who can be dangerous but chooses
not to be and chooses to control it that
to me is like a really high aspiration
for a way of living and that might be
wrong but but I love that I love the
aspiration of being able to do the
things that are dangerous but choosing
to control that danger so I have a
question with the prenup stuff I feel
like it's tough because it's almost like
if you have a kid you're screwed anyway
yeah when it comes to marriage like just
I've been doing this documentary on the
court system but even so I just don't
think I could ever advise a guy not to
get a prenup because
um because just the outcomes are so
catastrophic especially when I'm
learning like about
um men like committing suicide a lot
during that it's like a really big
problem and I started um asking Uber
drivers that I drive with and I'll just
start asking them questions and I found
out like I would guess like one out of
four of my Uber drivers they somehow
were in the court system
in some way so it's like all these men
that were just financially ruined and
they're 40 to their 50s to the point
they're never going to come back so do
you advise men to like do the same route
that you did because I would just have a
hard time doing that my you know I'm a
logical guy and I like to think of like
in things about mitigating risk probably
I made a very sub-optimal decision
um I'm very happy with my decision there
was a personal choice for me to you know
I I get really hard for commitment I get
hard for discipline it's just how it
commitment turns me on I've done one
thing in my life you know at a
university selling door-to-door I
started a company that's I sold suits
the door to door in Office Buildings
which has just grown to 20 countries we
now have over 100 people working at our
company I've only that's the only thing
I've done I don't like jumping around I
don't like to I don't like to look for
success in places that I don't know they
exist I don't like to
I don't like to look at my neighbor's
lawn I like to fertilize my own lawn so
for me that decision of commitment was
actually bigger than the risk that I
felt and that's just me not everybody's
gonna feel that way and um and that's
okay I mean I don't think I don't know
if there's a right answer I think this
is to me it's just first I was just
wondering you so many guys you Mentor so
I was just curious if you advise them
the same way I tell my guys this never
marry from a weak position never commit
from a weak position what I mean from a
weak position you know when you see red
flags and you're like everybody's you
know everybody knows that you see the
red flags and you choose to ignore them
why because that's the only option you
have and like I tell guys in our company
when they joined they're in the early
20s I'm like don't like
don't commit to the first girl you
freaking kiss man because you're like
there's things you're not gonna see like
go and run the hose just straight up I
go go through the 304s run it run it run
it run it so that sorry man that's
that's a very different I expect you to
have more of a trap that's very opposite
no no that is that is the optimum the op
the optimal thing that a man can do is
make himself as highly attractive to
women as possible as possible to
increase his pool and then pick the
option that optimizes for him and then
commit to that now some people might say
oh you should have three or four wives
some people want that I don't want that
like I'm I'm happy what did you think
about what he said earlier about guys
liking
um Alpha women sometimes like certain
guys well I found myself very my mom is
an alpha woman she's a high high income
earner
um compared to my dad so she actually
her career took off you know in computer
science she's got a master's computer
science so when we moved to Canada she
was like the Soviet engineer and her
career took off and my dad just remained
a humble mechanic
um and so I found myself at a young age
attracted to these women that were sort
of like argumentative uh sometimes would
cause a scene in public because that's
my mom
um and and wanted control and I made a
and again I I started finding myself
attracted to those women and I remember
my first serious girlfriend for two
years she never cooked a meal she said I
think it's beneath women to cook for men
in the bin it was and that wasn't the
only and that was the only that wasn't
the only thing can I share something
something that came in my mind basically
what you're saying is I get it because
you know for example a lot of people DM
me saying they talk about my chest and
that and I'm like is it because they've
got a fat mom and they've been like you
know when they're breastfeeding so
that's why they DM me talking about
wanting to lick my nipples and all that
so I get it it comes from childhood and
it comes from like little things like
you know what I mean
it comes from certain feelings must come
from childhood for them to have those
things as adults and I really believe
people that have fat mothers also like
fat people uh there is to study there's
a study that's been shown that poor men
prefer uh corpulent you know larger
women and what's interesting about that
I'm like I wonder I'm like I wonder if
it's because I know I I wonder if it's
because that's just the pool that they
have available to them you know and
obviously if you grow up poor there's
more likelihood you will be poor like of
course there is that like we know that
wow
um yeah sorry you were gonna no I was
just gonna actually like in terms
obviously every man is different yeah
you see me I couldn't be of a girl for
two years one year six months no food
you can't cook no dinner what's going on
you're probably just naturally better
with women than I was I wasn't naturally
good at it but but you know what I did
no I'm just serious like if you worked
where you worked and you were getting
something I'd like to know you got good
riddles I don't want to like maybe I
argued on being too you know we're
talking about being picky man don't care
about cooking they'll teach you how to
cook very much and my wife cooks all the
time and it's amazing and it's only
steak at our house now that's the rule
this month I have only eaten steak at
home this month the only thing but
anyways
um I I was intentional about again I'll
just share my thing this everybody's
different I had a book uh a vision book
I believed in actualization because my
mentor said you need to believe in it
okay I said fine I don't believe in
astrology but I'll try this stuff
whatever I had a book and one of the it
was like a folder there was like you
know goals in different areas and one of
the uh one of the dividers was about my
ideal mate and I actually described very
vividly with pictures what my ideal mate
would be to me that included not only
looks of course looks was there it was
number one uh for me it also included
you know background family really like I
got really detailed I had another Mentor
who was 39 he sold this company at 39
for 50 million bucks and just looked a
guy put me on the board of his freaking
company just I said dude I was like 24
like what are you doing
he goes Dimitri I want you to just sit
there and listen we're not going to pay
you I just want you to sit and listen so
you can be around these people and just
see how they talk see how they think and
just learn from them and I learned a ton
from that right and and he was like
girl's relationship with her father
matters a lot I don't know why I didn't
understand it but I said okay so I wrote
down I want my future wife to have an
amazing relationship with her dad and
respect her father this was the words he
said respect her father so I I got
really really detailed right now as I
got into like 24 25 26 my options opened
up profusely like it was like it was
like good times at that time but then I
was choosing from the women that made
themselves available to me and I and I
didn't turn the sex down let's put it
that way but in terms of like who I was
gonna wife up I knew exactly what I
wanted and that may be different from
different people but I really want to
take a strategic position and I was
willing to wait you know I was willing
to wait because the sex was available
you know I think I think if the guys
aren't getting laid then they're
probably just gonna yes get married for
the P that's a terrible decision I got
married for the character and I I you
know and that and that's been the intent
yeah Dmitry you've been sharing some
sort of special wisdom because I've
actually really been enjoying this yeah
yeah yeah it's actually your words um to
hear your experiences to to have it for
you also the fact that you've come from
a hardship background I must say I think
you deserve a clap you might as well
give him a clap guys yeah can I touch
them you guys know you guys know that
you guys you guys know that you guys
know that statistically if you're yeah I
was gonna say statistically if you're
wearing a suit people just believe you
more as an expert so um
you know what's interesting when you
were talking about
um
no tattoos no I don't know if you said
piercings and no piercings no tattoos
there she is
[Laughter]
it's interesting because when I was
growing up my mom would always say that
to me she'd be like you can't get a
tattoo like you and I would be like Mom
you're so judgmental why would you say
that you know and I would I would always
be you know just arguing with my mom
about it and she would always tell me
you can't get tattoos no peers you know
this no that and um I made it to 18
right and I went to Germany for the
summer and I I was thinking I was like
maybe I will just piss my mouth you know
you're 18 right please don't get a
swastika no no no
I didn't I didn't end up doing it but
it's like one of the things I'm so
thankful for now is that like my mom
just like beat that into me like no
heavy makeup no no tattoos no don't like
stay in shape like all that stuff like
I'm just yeah and it's interesting you
say that because what I noticed is like
my brother is like they won't even give
a girl like a second look if they say
she's got any tattoos that are visible
and and it's interesting it's sad
because sometimes times like girls are
so beautiful but it's like they'll get
like a sleeve or they'll get something
I'm like why are you a nice thing yeah
yeah is it is it someone without tattoo
or without person better than someone
that has them like that's a great
question very good question does it make
them greater than the one that doesn't
happen yeah
and there's no tattoos no tattoos I love
makeup I love that's just me I'm a girly
girl you know what I mean but it's true
like my mum was always like no tattoos
I was raised yeah what is it what is it
about tattoos though you want to hear
something crazy I value Purity
I just I had to learn about myself like
why do I feel that way and then I
introspect I value Purity was number one
and and again I know that some people
listen to this or even here are not
gonna agree with me that's okay I don't
I don't make your decisions you make
your decision I'm just telling you my
own perspective like I value Purity and
I think it shows a lack of impulse
control
sorry what do you define has a purity
just clean body
yes partially yeah like this it's
symbolic right I understand it's not
it's not physical it's not a physical
it's symbolic yeah like and by the way I
see you have tattoos I'm not like you're
I'm sure that like 99 of men would
disagree with me on this so I'm probably
not statistically correct here so just
know that you're more qualified and many
men's eyes than less qualified because
I'm sure other men would see that as fun
and uh and expressive and and maybe
um no they don't whatever I don't know I
don't know but I know you can find it
attractive it depends on the type of guy
you're going before because that guys
that from like a corporate background
like that's not what they go for
technically from a business
why when they say birds of a feather
flock together
I think we need to always Circle back
around to that because
if I date somebody completely out of my
character completely out of the people I
vibrate on like this frequency of course
I'm gonna have to challenge myself I'm
I'm going to want to get my tattoos
lasered and stuff so if you want to get
into that
um level of people you know those those
kind of people you want to be around
Millionaires and you want to have a
millionaire husband and all of those
things it comes at a price
yeah but do you actually feel like just
because like people don't have tattoos
and piercing they can be more successful
than people in relationships yeah my
brother so minority though I'm one of
them so I have I have a family of ten
five boys five girls and um out of my
five brothers I think four make six
figures so four are in the top like five
to ten percent of earners
um and none of them date women with
tattoos like they refuse they want to
ask
um the oldest if I can ask how old is
the oldest brother
um he the oldest brother is
33. he just got married and as first kid
we should clarify that we should clarify
that like just because a man will sleep
with you and we all know this doesn't
mean that he'll commit to you like it
doesn't mean that it doesn't mean that
man won't sleep like I had lots of girls
that had tattoos but but I knew that I
wasn't going to be like when you're
talking about yeah
we're not saying that we actually just
discussing about if someone that doesn't
have tattoo and piercing why would it be
better than someone that has them like
um it's the same thing as someone that
is wearing a suit and someone that is
wearing just jeans and just something
casual that's someone that wear a suit
makes someone like it does in a way in a
way it signals well
appearance right and that's the same
point so so to to women we we like men
in suits in general by and large because
it signals well we men like women
without piercings and without tattoos
because it signals Purity and Life
Choices why would you wear a white dress
at the wedding because it's a symbol
yeah I feel like with tattoos first year
they look good and all that but then
when you get older and wrinkled I'm
sorry it just looks like mess on the
body and even what you were saying like
birds are the same feather
we have another um I have another Talent
here and he's got a sleeve full of
tattoos and he even says himself he
prefers women without them that's true
but can I say just something yeah when I
was like younger right
um I used to have like piercings because
I love piercings so whatsoever yeah I
was 14 I was the only one having
piercings Nails whatsoever ear but I can
tell you for a fact that it was the
purest one because at 1315 I was not
going with any guy I was on my own I was
and the girls that they had the family
that they were eventually give them
curfew for going home at 10 11 o'clock
or they need to have piercing or they
didn't have tattoo they were the one
that they were dirty that more dirt to
them well and and there sometimes that
happens like sure but but this is the
thing if you're advertising yourself one
way so if you have a sign on yourself
and you're advertising that you're not
here how would they know yeah I know
it's like man if it walks like that's
what I'm saying because nowadays but
that's that's what I'm saying because
nowadays the society gets only to see
like the appearance They Don't Really
everything is superficial right but we
okay do you want do you want to date a
guy taller than you yeah of course okay
but so that's the difference of course
that's appearance that's judging a guy
basically okay well not because of her
nature the men right and for nature men
like women that are pure because
historically they had to ensure
paternity so they don't want a girl
that's been around and if a girl has
tattoos and a lot of piercings that's
what they associate it with yeah but uh
we can even talk about how many people
from New Zealand like ages and ages ago
they used to have tattoos on their
bodies or they used to have symptoms on
their bodies and which cultures
all these people that they used to have
tattoos in England in England we're not
talking about people we're in we're in
England
okay but okay anyway it doesn't it
doesn't really matter what the culture
was back then because it doesn't because
we're talking the culture do we live
back then no no but what I'm saying is
what I could say what I can say is that
it's it's already it's embedded in our
DNA though no matter where we are in the
world there is a specific thing that
brings me in that throws me in that
attracts me that does particular things
to my DNA and that's why I biologically
want this man I don't care that he has
four children and four baby mothers I
don't care that he doesn't provide
because at the end of the day nature to
Nature
there is something within him that's
deeper than what what Society sees him
as so you're Russian Roulette and your
relationships yeah no and I don't get in
relationships with him because that I
think at the end of the day me being in
a relationship with myself is more
important than being in a relationship
man I mean in a relationship with a man
I need to break this down I need to
break this being in a relationship with
yourself is more important than being in
a relationship with a man who
that's what we're added on who what
sorry finish it then so I'm saying in
order for me to be in a proper
relationship I need to know that that
man is secure whether that means that
I'm choosing a man who's not probably in
a particular position where I would want
to have his children I do believe that
me loving this man and having him commit
to me could potentially make him the man
he's meant to be if he lets me so be
that woman for him so you're gonna make
the man so the man's gonna commit to you
and you're going to make him into what
you want him to be not about what I want
him to be but what what he could be he
should be naturally okay so you're gonna
do societies why would you pick a guy
that you have to make him into what he
should be why wouldn't you just pick a
guy that's there that's because there
are certain men who see this is and
that's what I'm saying because I think
I've had a lot of offers of marriage a
lot oh lucky lady no like like in the
last three months I can tell you that
[Music]
I wish I had a lot of people proposing
to me a lot of times
I mean you kind of did right there when
you're saying I'm gonna make him into
the man he wants to it's just like no no
no
you got my words honestly I feel like
men that are going to be successful are
going to be successful regardless of the
women I think I think Dimitri right
there whether you met your wife or
didn't meet your wife I'm sure she is
but is it wrong for a woman
I mean yeah I think I think women just
take too much credit everything's on us
we do everything
to multiply that's what women do we
multiply I mean you give us
a house
stop so we'll have these we'll have
these modern women these modern modern
women that are so not traditional it's
just so obvious that it's unfortunate
I'm not talking about too personally but
I'm talking about in general so if you
keep ad-libbing you're gonna go okay
thank you so this is this is the thing
with with modern women it's like very
very clear not traditional and then
they'll say I make the house into a home
well but that's what women what percent
of women really do that what percent of
women why we're really raised to be wise
what percent of ruined women really know
how to have family traditions what
percent of women really value the family
what percent of women really aren't out
every week let us know because that is
the foundation is a woman makes a house
into a home and that's not that's why
they say when you look at a society and
see how it's doing you look at the women
and the women today they're overweight
they've slept with more people and and
we're less successful in relationships
we're the ones the way Society has gone
they've made it more accepted for women
to be by themselves half the kids and
not have the money involved why haven't
they given men a lot of incentive to
stay at home because all right a woman
can be high on this and high
statistically and that but really untrue
really the man it's all down to him in a
way he will make the proposal he would
choose his wife and all of that so why
has not the system give more incentive
for the men to stay okay I can tell you
why actually so when um the system
[Music]
no it's it's the women it's the women's
choices so because women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 of their college
educated so the women are the ones
ruining the relationships who ruins the
relationship the one that stays the one
that leaves the quitter ruins it cannot
just say the women have more incentive
to be by themselves correct and why is
that because they financially ruin men
in order to financially the system wants
to tax everybody
no no no I'll tell you I'll tell you why
because I'm actually researching if you
want to I'm actually I'll tell you I'll
tell you why if you want to know because
I'm actually researching this the issue
is that the the politicians have no
incentive to change the laws because the
biggest group of Swing voters is women
and single mothers are the biggest
voters so why would they take away the
benefits of single mothers even if men
are committing suicide every single day
because of these policies
now some could argue that women
shouldn't vote
women got to vote but can you see where
I'm coming from like the incentives are
crazy now let me tell you something this
is where I'm coming options are crazy
but we don't have to take them women
don't have to take those which I haven't
yeah I'm not talking about you no but
I'm one person that hasn't I'm the woman
that hasn't you know but let me tell you
something let me tell you something I
had my best friend from school right and
I don't even want to break down their
parents right now I love you I love you
all but my best friend from school free
kids no husband no actually she had a
fiance she committed suicide like why
would my best friend from school do that
now that's where I'm coming from and
that's why I had to escape that because
look where my best friend is today you
know you had to escape what I had to
escape that environment that environment
yeah I'll be in a bit toxic a bit
generational curves she killed herself
because I did I don't know maybe because
I don't know why I don't know why we
don't know why but she you know she left
her family her everybody was so close
and you know
even though these women are saying that
they're gonna leave they're gonna do
this they're still not happy in in
making that choice but then the men
still don't have no incentive to come
back or to stay or to make it work with
the women that then they bear children
with you know but that's that's just
that narrative just isn't true it's just
wrong because because the men are not
leaving the women are leaving women
with two kids right okay but that's the
exception it's not the rule
I'm saying okay out of 10 marriages if
there's 10 marriages two are the men
leaving eight are the women leaving so
who's the problem
all right Believers maybe the easy
answer Believers leave us which is the
women but it's the incentives that they
have they probably be like oh I've got
too much um I don't know
but this is but this is the thing this
is why I say modern women are selfish
because it's me me before the family oh
even if they have the incentives like a
true traditional woman would never take
them but she doesn't care because she
cares about the kids first maybe they're
coming from a place where they've seen
that okay the traditional woman has been
unhappy for the most of her life been
unhappy that's statistics
but that's that's not true that's not
true it's true either when women when
families are happier than women without
families eighty percent of women that
are single and childless are not happy
that they're that right
the single most unhappiest demographic
there's lots of data on this this 40
year old single unmarried women the
single most unhappiest demographic like
yeah I'm not saying everybody is like
statistics you know don't apply to
individuals but that's just like data
it's just and it's just right definitely
and it's like why do we why do we I feel
like Hollywood Hollywood
has brainwashed us into thinking that
traditional women were not happy because
there were unhappy times you know I I
know a couple and I've told the story a
couple times this couple they were they
were together and the woman
um the man actually left the house for
for a side chick so he left he left the
house completely left her and this woman
was so Catholic that she prayed she
prayed to God for a solution she said
God please God like I send my husband
home I just want to work it out side
chick died
side chick she died
and and he came home right and they
stayed married for 50 years that sounds
like murder Pearl
I promise they lived I promise I promise
no murder no murder but but that's what
I mean and and she wasn't spiteful she
didn't hold it over his head she she
looked at herself and said what how did
I contribute to this and how can we
solve it but women women like that don't
exist anymore that doesn't exist it's
true they're really dying yeah like
women that really believed the families
before me but why why are the women but
you got to ask yourself these questions
why are the women turning back on their
men why because they're selfish
apart from being selfish I need more
than selfishness because because I mean
some of the number like some of the top
indicators of divorce are um uh
Financial
um cheating
um what are the other ones it's like
Financial cheating and
irreconcilable differences yeah that's
like the top three times are married 85
Google it 85 of millionaires are married
no that's good because that means that
they have a strong woman behind them
successful
we take way too much credit I'll give
you an example now Melinda Melinda Gates
him Bill Gates okay Melinda Gates and
Bill Gates was Bill Gates suddenly lost
and not so now don't get me wrong I'm
not saying that the women have no part
to play what happened the successful men
are going to be successful regardless
when when Melinda or let's take um the
Bezos Jeff Bezos and whatever whatever
like he got richer she got poorer was
she that important
when it comes to his success was he not
going to be successful when raising the
kids having his own family that's that's
the point like what behind every
successful man is not always a
successful woman it's a supportive woman
if the statistics are 85 of millions out
there you know of a millionaires they're
married right that means that they're
truly happy they're happy to make money
they're happy to go home they're happy
to be with their wives and happiness and
they're not marrying you
that should be a concern no it's not
about me because you're statistics
you're saying
here and blah blah blah successful this
and that it's like where
I chose not to be okay I chose not to be
we have choices like she says women are
always breaking up behind maybe it was
me I walked away I did do you think do
you think that you have no room for
improvement there's no no room there's
room there's a lot so you've got to do
it with the right so so why why is that
your answer so because it's like if
someone says to me millionaires aren't
trying to marry you I would be like okay
well
it's 85 I don't know why you had to
break it though
listen okay it's the question is how can
I improve to get there if you're not
where you want to be how can you improve
to get there but you have to admit
there's a problem by taking the steps
and if you're being distracted by men
that you know they're not going to be
supportive on your journey okay it's
gonna be a frequent Journey if you had a
partner and you turn around I mean no
can I just say if you had a partner and
you turn around to him and say babe I'm
honest I'm gonna quit my job and I'm
gonna be a tick tocker it's gonna look
at you like what though really he ain't
gonna even see your vision or your gold
would you want your message
I didn't I had I I didn't have a
boyfriend then but honestly when I told
my dad he supported me
no but this is this is it's just because
it should but just because this is and
not many men listen my gosh listen
listen just because that's the men you
pick that's the men you deal with i i
that's that's the men that you pick and
the all men are not like that wow most
men that I that I've dated I'm extremely
supportive and I'll be fair I must admit
the man who has been truly supportive
I'm just not attracted to him obviously
that is my personal life choice why is
it so wrong for me it's that choice it's
not it's not wrong but it's like anytime
anyone says anything to you it's like
you're arguing I just know but I'll have
you know I'm I'm probably coming from a
place where I'm talking from a woman
who's probably coming from the um
another different background and it
hasn't been so privileged I mean so many
people I talk to oh my god dude I talked
to I've talked to hundreds I can't
imagine I've talked to hundreds and and
I'm telling you you sound
it he said it sounds delusional like the
way you talk just sounds so good it's
not it is
in order to quit your job and be a
tick-tocker you've got to be and yeah
but this is the thing I have outcomes
yes outcomes and and when and when and
when I figured out I wasn't getting it
out listen listen and when you figure
out you're not getting the outcome you
want you have to change something
and there were times where I was not
getting the outcome I wanted and I had
to change something but when you it's
like there's no you act like there's no
room for improvement ever what do you
mean based that based on the way you've
you've conducted yourself in this
conversation and you you can take it or
leave it it's your life it's not room
for improvement I don't get that part
can I um I have a really funny this is a
Jerry Seinfeld joke and it's like it's
been called the I think it's Jerry
Seinfeld and I want to give the right
credit he said the funniest thing ever
is that when you see two homeless people
talking to each other one is giving the
other advice oh bless let's just think
about that again yes I want to say it
again when you see two home when you see
two homeless people talking to each
other one is giving the other advice
yeah so the point though right so that's
really kind of funny it's like what's he
tell yeah do this oh okay like it's like
it's so absurdly funny yeah yeah one of
the things I teach the young fellows and
gals in our company I say this really
with no irony say never take advice from
somebody with whom you wouldn't trade
lives with so guys if you're watching
this right now Pearl you have a like
awesome audience they're they're trying
to decipher what's true what's not true
because they're getting different
messages right look at the person that
you would love their life and follow
their advice and then look at the person
that you would not want their life and
do the opposite and that's that's
probably the the core of what people
want to get at
okay guys I'm gonna Read Super Chat um
and then I think we're gonna close out
the show
um
guys make sure you like the video and
all super chats are going towards
um blessing a blessing what tell them
what camera you want blessing I gotta
get this to the Super Chat button
let's get that camera how much is it
five something five okay
well can I just compliment what you're
doing is brilliant this is leadership
like I don't know what your dad told you
or if you just picked it up like this is
amazing like you have a guy that's like
employed by you or working with you and
you give them a vision and a goal
something that can be achieved you make
it public so you crystallize it so
you're committed to that goalie dude she
cares about you and she actually wants
you to win yeah that's freaking great
leadership man I'm really like that like
that you have like that's really
impressive see I just I've always felt
like
my skill has always been getting the
most talented people in a room and
blessing genuinely is the best producer
and there's no one better than blessing
well you posted on um you posted on
LinkedIn today that you were looking for
an editor or something and I have a guy
that's got I think uh 1.6 million
followers there on LinkedIn and I tagged
them in and he's been boosting that post
check it out because I was like when I
met your team last time I went back to
my video guy I'm like he couldn't come
on this trip and you need to come with
me you need to come with me because we
need to learn from these guys because
they're Pros like really good people
yeah no I mean I I've just always felt
like you should give
because I'm just not very Money
Motivated I'm just very like project
motivated and so I just felt like if I
have someone that's really talented like
why would I not give them all the
resources that they can to and you know
now I think we have the best set on
YouTube
um in my opinion shout out blessing
yeah shout out to you shout out to me
um but yeah guys but he does run my
credit card like it's no tomorrow oh my
God he just goes crazy I had to ban him
for like a month or two sorry we were
running out of money you know what I
mean stop sending super chats um okay
Dion C Dimitri is King Matt butcher
getting back on the subject the
millionaires don't marry 304 as the end
bring Dimitri back Pearl uh where can I
find the source through your stats we're
trying to put together a link tree
sorry I've just been busy um xeros lost
um a woman's choices are just for sex
and not for a relationship crazy world
crazy times questions of the panel
thinking about making a paternity test
mandatory during our at child's birth
Dimitri don't worry um I want to and too
many others feel the same way about
tattoos it's a sign she's a 304 or has
trauma most men are conservative by
Nature 93 top birds of the same feather
flock together
uh Chris your prenup advice is
destructive towards most men thank you
Sam G Abby priority Abby prioritizes
winning an argument over
um okay then let me refresh it just to
make sure there's no other super chats
um okay Jalen Hawkings um Pearl is doing
the hard work out there shout out to
blessing um interracial relationships to
know successes to be familiar with
failure ready to learn never give up on
your goal and always be willing to
listen to those
who are more knowledgeable
um okay
so
um thank you guys for coming
um did we lose half the panel
I think at home yeah it's getting late
okay
um all right guys
um final thoughts and any social media
you want to plug go ahead so starting
you can start and then you go yeah go
ahead
um
this was fun this was fun usually I'm on
the um on the other side of the screen
um tuning in and obviously just
observing everyone's opinions are and
the stats and things and maybe maybe the
feelings have to get left in the in the
feeling box and the logic has to come
out sooner or later but that's for my
journey my evolving Journey but one
thing I will leave not the journeys yeah
come with me to Cape Town let's go
but I'll show you the journey no I'm not
going on that Journey no I've heard too
much about these Journeys why are there
so many boners on every journey
I can't hear anyone that's probably why
um
the last I just wanted to say something
earlier on is that
I think men like Dimitri
um they they build societies
yeah and um there are other men who you
know coach soccer teams and
build communities within that Society
I think everyone in this world
truthfully has a role to play and we'll
just have to wait and see how it plays
out but yeah you can follow me on
Instagram uh golden gem underscore
thanks
okay what's the question
final thoughts Instagram Final Four
be less judgmental okay judge more don't
listen
yeah I don't know I don't know but
um people have different roads to leave
and they have to be
that image or whatever
for whatever role they play and
um
you just gotta respect everybody's
decision and I believe in life there's
no wrong or right decision it's a
journey enjoy I just I'm sorry I need to
ask one thing so if I if I decide to do
heroin tomorrow no choice there's that's
not a wrong decision it's an experience
so there is a wrong and a right decision
for you for me for her yes okay from
what you would I feel like I feel like
I've done that I'll probably haven't
been I don't know I don't know I don't
know maybe I'm just on a mad spiritual
joke that's just different walks and I'm
just open this is completely yeah the
Walk of heroin which is just a walk
I mean why would women want to stay in a
relationship when a man keeps on
cheating on them I mean maybe the
percentage are hard women love cheaters
I mean if it's just a high percentage I
know because I've just heard about too
many ex-boyfriends that [__] it's just
like I hear about them all the goddamn
time do you want people to stay in their
misery
I want women to pick and stop whining
about their choices so I'm really tired
of them
no no they never they never they never
whine about their choices to leave it's
really common for them to accuse men of
abuse with no evidence and it's also I'm
just really tired of them picking men
that are obviously going to cheat that
nobody is surprised is cheated and then
they're gonna cry and say they're not
happy with the cheating the man could
cheat two years three years down the
line though and he could and he could
but in my experience most of the time
there's at least 10 billion warning
signs and I'm sick of everyone whining I
don't know I I don't know
girls stop whining okay stay with your
man remember she said she's a good judge
of character
no I didn't say that you literally said
that
she changed her mind it's okay
oh okay
okay go ahead okay go ahead all right
cool so I too have had a really good
time today
um definitely more listening for me
today as opposed to getting involved
Dimitri I feel like your experiences and
the stories that you've shared with us
have been very insightful Pearl was
always ever the ever the temptress and
the you know
um making people question what they've
asked and things like this oh sorry or
they've what they've answered and stuff
so it's been very entertaining to watch
for sure
um I would definitely say that there
needs to be more listening and not so
much responding just as a general no not
in this not in here I mean as a in
general listen pay attention and what
you're not changing you are choosing and
you can hit me up on the socials just
underscore leash on Instagram and um
yeah maybe a little bit more involvement
from me next time for sure
do you wanna if you want to do your
final thoughts you can come sit down
yeah yeah go ahead you can sit good go
ahead go ahead while she sits well yeah
it's been really fun listening to
different opinions and what people think
about the topic we discussed and thing I
want to shout out is if you want to be a
stud
lgfgfashionhouse.com we're hiring
[Music]
I want to tell you very much thank you
very much for giving us the opportunity
to share our ideas
um I like very much the way you speak
and the way you share your ideas and
yeah that's pretty much yeah thank you
for coming uh star of the show so guys
listen up uh real quick first of all bro
thank you for I wasn't expecting to be
in London today and I messaged your
assistant to Lula and she was like come
on I'm like cool thank you so much um
look like there's some kind of a tenant
here that like good decisions and bad
decisions don't exist please don't
listen to that do not ruin your life
there are bad decisions and usually
um you and the hard part like being a
young person I'm sure your audience is
pretty young is like navigating life and
trying to figure out what's good and
what's bad like that's really hard
because you know we don't always have
good role models we don't always have
good examples we just don't know you
know
um but if you're a young
young uh you know fella or gal like like
if you're if you're in that stage where
you're choosing a career if you're
choosing the path of your life if you
are looking for potentially for mentors
and here's why because you realize that
your friends kind of suck now they're
bad people but they're just not getting
you to where you want to go and I think
everybody has that realization at some
point in their life if that's you right
now and you're like hey I'm looking for
something to to positively move my life
in a positive direction yes we are
hiring we teach young men and women the
Art and Science of sales which includes
a ton of rejection Pearl you've gone
through that and it built some character
man you know there's times you hate it
of course but but you can't grow without
doing things that you absolutely despise
because otherwise you're just sitting on
a chair you know
um so if you're looking to build that
character you know lgfg that's our
company lgbg.com or lgbfashionhouse.com
you can also find us under LGBT fashion
house on Instagram you've seen our work
on Eddie Hall on Jordan Peterson uh on a
ton of celebrities on on the Rock even
um so guys lgbgfashionhouse.com if
you're interested we uh we're hiring
yeah and me next
let's go and the suit right uh well
Camille how many suits do you have now
and you've been so you've got three
suits in your first year and how much is
it what's an average suit that you're
wearing costs what's that suit you're
wearing costs 2K pounds yeah that's a
three piece by the way two and a half
yeah two and a half can 20 21 year old
kid wearing a two and a half thousand
pound suit in his first year in the
company that's why he's plugging us it's
not because I'm paying him to plug even
though I totally will it's because it's
because he believes in it guys that's it
just offering some growth man
um okay Marlena says end game is biology
and then
um lady or 11 111 Shamir a lady with the
best if a bird had your brain it would
fly backwards sorry
um Okay so
all right guys a couple announcements
before we end the show
um first things first guys two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
four membership tiers um just signing
for the fourth tier guys
um honestly I you will get so much value
out of that call I can talk your ear off
and just [__] you can avoid when doing a
show I've wasted you know a million
subscribers in a year was a lot of work
and I could show you how to not waste as
much time as I did because let me tell
you there's a lot of places where I went
wrong
um also Instagram they took away my
Instagram just pearly things one go
follow my new one guys I'm so mad they
took away my fifth Tick Tock I'm so
tired of starting over on this app I'm
so tired
um but it's just pearly things
um yeah because they just put my new
user my old username up for grabs Rumble
go follow uh wife school go subscribe um
I I had Maggie the substitute teacher
taught me um what to cook your husband
in a day so we she went through like
every meal that we would prepare would
be a good meal and the whole team tried
it so um we have a really
um
uh
uh sign up to the Google form that
should be in the chat for our next
Meetup we want to take people that were
musicians from the show and do like a
little like I don't know concert I think
it's gonna be fun I play guitar so I
might do something too
um and watch out for our
Penthouse tour next week so thank you
guys for watching and we will talk to
you next time what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things YouTube channel
and welcome to the Pre-K ate
[Applause]
I agree with you I think they do do it
for the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not really attention so you can
kind of do a cheat code you can go get a
BBL get a nice body and you do get more
attention from them than if you're flat
right but here's the thing though no no
but but listen though if it goes so
deeper though because I know what you're
talking about and he has a great body
yeah so you got to think about how far
down deep that she is within watching
the Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazines
great body doesn't look good to a man
wait you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest end is for women for women
so like the women have higher beauty
standards to me yes and that's what's
making women feel like they need to
comply with these standards who's
pickier men or women men and women are
more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all the men do you think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard and they're more rigid
than women I think men are pickier than
women 100 certainly but they will not
marry they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last
vagina boobs
lingerie yeah
yeah when I finished it I felt very
degraded I felt very like why did I
actually do that now I know there's
girls out there who do that they don't
feel that way that is perfectly fine you
do you you feel the way you feel but me
personally like like in the future how
like when I have kids and all the future
and if my kids found out about that
they'll probably get bullied in school
there are people like oh your mom doing
this your mom doing that and your man as
well he's not going to if you don't
respect yourself and you're selling your
body online I can't speak for everyone I
can just speak for myself if you're
selling your body online like that
there's not there's not a high risk